oh all right uh it's being a little past
11 maybe 1101 uh I'm gonna go ahead and
open the first meeting of uh official
meeting of division three for this
session
and before we get into talking with our
guests I I wanted to offer uh just sort
of some admin overview things
um keep in mind that uh this is uh we're
we're streaming live
are do you know if the machines turned
on
okay how do I tell am I supposed to be
able to see and see a red light up there
or something or how to
okay I I mean I know I we don't need to
do that right now but it would be nice
if I could self-identify if we're turned
on
oh that is brilliant
that is so smart
oh okay good good good
um okay because we're virtual I just
want to remind everyone of uh microphone
discipline you know try to really lean
into and talk talk into the microphone
the red light means you're on
um if anyone wants handouts they're
available digitally online
um do you want to say how to find them
I know there is a division division link
uh website Mr Ripple sent it around if
anybody would like to have me distribute
it I will do that but it is on the
website
yeah I mostly was thinking for the
anyone who may be watching us stream if
they wanted to go navigate to the to the
website
um all right Mr chair is there a way
that the link can be put somewhere in
the notes on our stream for those
I don't know how to do that through
um the YouTube but if we could put it in
the comments that would be great for the
users uh thank you I don't I don't know
anything unless Mr Ripple is here is uh
unfortunate truth so
um and then on the microphone if you
when you do talk get get more into it if
you wouldn't mind
um so miss Mr Ripple while you were out
representative Hull had a idea on making
sure the public can see easily where the
handouts are is there some way on the on
the streaming to put the link to the
where the documents are
I'm I could check with gcts and see if
they can do that I'm not sure okay again
not not urgent not now just you know
just kind of Futures okay and and then
you know the if since we're streaming
this is going to be on an on uh on our
archive so people can will be able to
come back and and and watch this later
uh and so uh I just want to remind us
all that uh we want we want to manage
and maintain our uh decorum
um one of the things I'm willing to uh
experiment with and I'm kind of happy
with is is based on how this committee
has worked in the past if you have
questions for a witness all you need to
do is is let me know that you got two
three questions or something uh and uh I
I I'm I'm happy to just let you run and
have a good conversation without having
to continuously come back to me asking
for a follow-up I mean we can do it that
way but but I think there's the more
natural speech is good and and I I think
that'll work but if it doesn't I reserve
the right to change that and then on
laptops it was
um okay
so the technical policy of the speaker
is that we're not supposed to have
laptops up in public sessions now now
technically every time we have a uh a
division meeting this is a work meeting
this isn't this isn't meant to be a
public hearing as much so I think we
could have a technical exception to
where we can have laptops but here's the
exception I'm going to offer us and that
is the point of not having laptops up is
because we ought to be
providing a non-verbal communication
back to the public that we're listening
to the testimony and we're paying
attention but but I also know that we
have people like representative erf who
are great with the spreadsheets who just
keep track of everything so what I'm
going to say is go ahead and use your
discretion on how you're going to use
your laptop but keep it in the back of
your mind that we want to be you know
present for the Witnesses in the public
is there anything else you want me to
go ahead
okay thank you Mr chairman uh in the
calendar the thought was it may be nice
to have all the topics laid out that
will be presented along with the times
so for example coming up on this Friday
we'll have strategic I.T plan in
progress at 2 30 and the like so I would
just suggest that moving forward the
calendar entry be very specific with
regards to the topics and the times so
this public would know when to come if
they were interested in a particular
topic or not thank you
so so so I I I I agree mostly with what
you just said I I don't think the times
the the after we kick off I don't think
the subsequent times for most of our
stuff are is it just as important as as
getting the topics and the sequence
what do you think about them Miss Ripple
uh I I think that might be for the best
just because if you schedule exact times
as I know they had been doing in some of
the other divisions
um you could end up with a lot of a lot
of dead air so to speak if you get done
early and have to wait for the next
presentation
all right uh thank you are anyone else
on the committee you got sort of admin
notes admin questions rules of the road
any anything all right so with that I
think we are ready to kick off uh our
inaugural meeting and I have a stand for
an HHS roadmap and the road map includes
three key things positions metrics and
salary and and I'll I'll leave it to the
department how how you come up and
foreign
good morning members of the committee my
name is Nathan white I'm the Chief
Financial Officer for DHHS
good morning I'm Lori Weaver interim
commissioner for HHS
and so um before you you have a
PowerPoint presentation and on page two
of the of the document there is an
agenda and so today we're going to be
opening up with just a brief brief
discussion on the mission and
responsibilities of the department
that'll be followed by the
commissioner's 2023 strategy
we'll then be going into some of the
Staffing level details we'll be talking
a little bit about contractors and then
contract quality management and then
Department metrics and with that I will
hand it over to the commissioner we're
going to adjust the uh this shade so
that you don't look like you're getting
a sunburn talking to us and and and for
the people in line
um to give you more clarity on how you
can find these documents if you go into
the general court under the house you'll
see the LBA under the LBA you you can
find division three where division three
in in in this document that we're
briefing is there all right well welcome
thank you good morning so we put
together a deck to be able to walk us
through I think what uh some of Nathan
already covered in hopefully answering
some of the questions that the committee
may have on the first slide is just an
overview of the mission and
responsibilities of our department
um if if you go to slide four where it
says uh missionary responsibilities it
sort of chunks it out into four general
areas and I know a lot of folks are
familiar with the department but just
for those that may not be
um we kind of Chunk it out into these
four categories of Education delivering
Services
delivering Services is typically in the
form of Case Management Services with
the exception of our Direct Care
Facilities which are listed as New
Hampshire hospital Gun Club Hampstead
and youth services Center protecting the
health and safety of our citizens and
providing regulatory oversight so that's
probably like the most Cliff note
version you'll ever get of what does the
department do because within this there
are multiple things and and you know I
was just saying this morning I I've been
at the department for 25 years very
familiar with the business that we do
and I'm still learning things
um every every time so I mean I know the
big stuff but in terms of the little
nuances but when we think about our
staff we have Direct Care staff
non-direct Care staff we have a lot of
different areas we have seven divisions
and that sort of segues into the the org
chart slide where you have here this is
um
our attempt at its most simplest version
of to try to take the department at a
macro level at least from the office of
the commissioner you'll have the
commissioner you'll have the deputy
which was my prior role you'll see in
terms of the operations happening excuse
me over to the left but when you go over
to the right it chunks out we take our
associate Commissioners and then we give
them portfolios right so the whole idea
is that there's integration at this
higher leadership level so that they
understand the business of the
department but they are also responsible
for the day-to-day of these areas so we
have uh Ann Landry who's over Public
Health Services Medicaid and our office
of Health Equity Marissa hen is over
areas of dcyf Behavioral Health and
Hampstead Hospital and then Christine
santinello is economic housing and
long-term Support Services those are are
seven divisions and they're pretty large
but again seeking for integration and
then there's there's the other uh
positions that are below that so we have
chief medical officer which is Dr
Jonathan Ballard which some of you may
know
um we have our Chief Financial Officer
uh sitting right here right next to me
um Chief legal officer uh as well as our
we have our
New Hampshire hospital CEO currently
reports to the commissioner position let
me ask you a couple questions I I don't
want to interrupt your discussion on the
org chart are you done with the org
chart I am okay so two questions I the
the Deputy Commissioner position is kind
of interesting because it's your it's
your full-time position but you're an
interim now as as the overall
commissioner and I'm I'm just curious uh
to the extent that you all have a
publicly facing position on on what
you're going to do with the Deputy
Commissioner position are you are you
going to look for an interim for that as
well are you going to try to hire
somebody are you reserving it just as a
fallback or not a fallback but you know
what I mean sure at this time we're not
going to be filling this position while
I'm in the role of interim the duties
that I had as Deputy have been dispersed
amongst the three associate
Commissioners for the time being and I
believe it is the intention at some
point to to fill that position so it's
not that we would be getting rid of it
it's just that during this time of
interim that's how we're managing it
okay so you're not concerned because
you've got delegation that you're not
concerned about the lack of leadership
in that area while you're doing a bigger
job
no I'm not concerned about it we have
very competent staff okay and then on
the other one uh I you know one of my
pet rocks is uh privacy and is is that
is that also a co-equal duty to the
chief legal officer or I forget do you
have a separate privacy officer we have
a separate privacy offer so if you go
over to the left that was one of the
areas that I was responsible for
information systems and that in that
Bureau we have a breakdown we have an
Epi HIPAA and we have a information
security officer but we also work with
doit for that function as well right and
so I recall your privacy officer is an
attorney and she's been there for like
five years or so could you just say her
name to remind me
the privacy officer
don't I don't want to put you on the
spot Kathy Bernhard that's it Kathy
bernhard's been there more than five
years oh okay she's been here a long
time all right okay go ahead thank you
so are there any other questions on the
word chart okay
um so uh representative you mentioned uh
road map um that's actually a a a point
I want to talk about in these next
couple of slides here is in the time
that I have as interim commissioner and
I you know interim who knows how long
that's going to be but let's just say
it's a year
um in that year what are we going to be
focusing on in the department people ask
what's your vision what are you going to
be doing it's it's challenging an
interim role right I'm not a four-term
year commissioner at least not at this
point um so I really am a little bit uh
Limited in what I can do in terms of
strategic planning but I'm not limited
in setting goals for the department and
asking us to move to those to that end
so when I chunk it out which is really
slide seven but I will go through those
with you really looking at it's been
it's been a long three years right we
we've been through a lot in the
department and we're tired and there's
some internal
improvements that can be made with some
of our systems and I'd like to take the
opportunity now to do that and it's a
good timing with a budget year as well
so if you were to look at the circles
that you have this is my way of creating
a visual to be able to talk to folks
about what are we going to be focusing
on and you'll notice that the big blue
bubble is invest in people and culture
we can't do the work of the department
without people without our staff and we
are a 21 vacancy rate right now we're at
a 21 vacancy rate maybe it's gone down
and Nathan's going to tell me like point
three percent or whatever but it's High
um you know I think you know I remember
the department a long time that's the
highest I ever remember it being and
granted circumstances it's not
surprising that it's that but the point
being is that I intend to build the
workforce up over the next 12 months as
well as getting people to stay right so
this isn't about just recruitment it's
about retention it's about creating an
environment where people want to stay
and want to work our staff are so proud
of the work that they do and they should
be very Mission driven but we can't rely
on that alone anymore we have to create
an environment where people feel valued
and that making a difference and I'm not
saying that we don't have that now but
we're going to be very intentional and
strategic
about that in the next 12 months and
hopefully longer than that if you go
over to the left bubble manage resources
effectively and efficiently
the department you know is we're at a
point where we really got to focus in
what are our priorities and the work
that we do and we don't we have very
limited time money and people to do that
work so historically the department is
good at doing a whole bunch of things
and bringing them inching them along a
little bit I really want to get to the
finish line and some of the work that we
need to do so that's an intentional
focus by leadership to every opportunity
that we have to make sure checking
ourselves that we are on track on goal
on target to meet that and using the
resources in the most efficient way
possible so that breaks down I'm
simplifying it at a macro level but it
breaks down into some pretty specific
goals that I'm not going to share with
you here right today I am introducing
this to our our organization next week
and the week after but I wanted to share
with you in light of what you're what
we're doing here today is that these are
this is a focus as well as the bubble
underneath the enhancing organizational
value that's really looking at our our
quality our division of quality and
integrity units so division.unit
um Meredith's here to talk a little bit
more about that but some of you may or
may not know I think it was right before
covert there was an executive order to
stand up this Division and then take it
out of just auditor audit and compliance
functions because that's you know that's
part of what we do but part of it was to
be strategic and proactive with making
sure that the dollars that we spend
we're getting what we're intending to
spend them for right that we're working
with our provider community that we're
able to procure for services that are
deliverable measurable and and bring
results so that's what that whole bubble
there is about so we talk about contract
monitoring management of contracts it's
more than getting the contract across
the Finish Line is it making a
difference is it working if it's not
working why what adjustments need to be
made so that's another thing to hold us
accountable the bubble on the far right
the promote thriving communities
that's really a connection with some of
the initiatives that we have going on
right now about getting the right
services to the right people at the
right time so when we think about things
like the behavioral health system we
know that there's some more work we can
be doing there with mobile crisis and
accessibility for that when we think
about children's system of care we have
an infrastructure where that has stood
up which is great but our providers are
short staffed so it's hard for them to
take kids when they don't have the bed
so so our systems are clogged so working
in on that Juvenile Justice
transformation you know really getting
to a re restorative rehabilitative
rather than a punitive model so that's
what that bubble there speaks to so
these are things that our senior
leadership on that prior page of the um
org chart are going to be responsible
for moving those commitments forward and
then working with our division
instructors and our staff to make these
things happen I've got 12 months which
is in a heartbeat will go by very
quickly so that that is our our Focus
any any questions on I I have a question
a couple questions anyone else from the
committee okay so uh under the promote
thriving communities uh you you offhand
were able to to mention a couple of uh
unmet needs and that you're addressing
um but if you step back and you think
okay what is the biggest what are the
biggest unmet needs for us to achieve
this goal of promoting thriving
communities is it is it substance abuse
is it uh just General Wellness is it
prenatal care I mean what as you just
step back what what are your biggest
priorities from an unmet needs
perspective
so if I if I may I would I would once I
have released all of the detail below
that then I would be able to share that
with you and it's not that I'm keeping
it top secret and it's not a simple
answer it's an awesome response but
um Nathan just so kindly pointed out to
me if you go to the next page uh
representative you'll see the
commitments break down into initiatives
which break down into goals and
deliverables so I'll be able to better
answer your question for specifically
what goals we have under there I I I
think I should just for uh new members
of the committee and for anyone curious
we're sort of doing something different
this budget cycle than what we've done
in the past we normally haven't really
gotten started on any uh a division or
excuse me any Department briefs until
after the governor's budget was released
and I I just want to thank you for being
willing to come in and start to talk us
before we're ready to talk numbers and
so so it's perfectly understandable that
uh you know you're not ready for uh the
whole detail because this is you're
doing us a courtesy because we only have
so much time before we have to be done
with our budget work and we're just
trying to pre-load some of it so thank
you for that
I I have a question on the culture
um how
are you are you ready or able to
describe the extent to which you're kind
of satisfied with the current culture
and you're fostering it or or is there
is there kind of a sort of a new
cultural Paradigm that you really see
the department needing to move towards
I think it's more the former I think
we're fostering I think we we have a
good
base of a culture but we could be great
we could be doing so much better so
we're going to build on what we're doing
well and go from there so it's uh it's a
work in progress but it
it's good okay I it's been a rough two
three years I don't know how you manage
a culture when everyone's running crazy
and and you're everything's virtual and
remote and to you know so so okay I I I
get that
um all right I I'm I'm ready for page
eight if you've not already completed it
sure let me I'll just quickly review for
page eight and we're in the process of
rolling this out with our organization
and we're working on this play with the
leadership team so I don't want to get
ahead of announcing it to you before my
staff so that's so we we these are all
uh are already defined out but we really
wanted to be able to take um an approach
that would allow us to demonstrate what
the goal is and what our progress was or
wasn't towards that so that could better
inform where we needed to go after that
so it's really about accountability and
measurement as well we plan to use um
you know some of our own tools in terms
of smartsheets and dashboards to be able
to use at a leadership management level
but we also intend to engage with our
Workforce and our providers as well to
let them know where we're at
okay I'm just just curious do you do you
do you see any I.T infrastructure
support to help you with sort of uh
managing I I used to call this
management by objectives do you do you
do you have
um it supported assistant that a home
management effort or is it all ad hoc no
we certainly do have I.T support we have
some really good tools that we'll be
using that we use right now and the
organization will use them for this okay
super
are there are there questions at this
point or representative Northern and
maybe go a little deeper into the whole
issue of
um the 21 vacancy rate and
how that's affecting you what you're
doing about it how you're trying to
manage without the 21 and what you
envision happening with your new budget
sure and we're going to talk a little
bit more about that in detail but just
to answer answer your question directly
um
we're getting by
um but but the cost of Getting By is
asking staff to do more and more and
more to the point of burnout right
that's not a culture that we want to
have right we want to have a culture
where people feel like I was hired to do
this and this is what I'm doing not a
million other things but people are
helping out all right we are actually
looking to move forward with some last
uh well working with the Department of
admin services on getting some access to
some tools that we currently don't have
which equates to recruitment activities
that we currently don't do because we
don't have the tools so we're looking at
some new tools and new resources to be
able to bring some people in and I'll
tell you we've done some of that already
and it's worked with particular
positions right
um it's harder in some of the um
we've all heard about the nursing
positions right those are the ones that
are really hard for sure and it's really
really super hard for us to compete with
that but even just you know in Nathan's
shop alone we're down like 25 Finance
people well being down 25 Finance people
means that bills don't maybe get paid on
time right so we're looking at systems
and efficiencies of ways to address that
but we really need
the ability to fill those positions so
even I there's a concern where positions
are vacant well we're working really
hard to fill them but sometimes we feel
them and then people leave right so the
net gain is hard getting harder to get
at
representative
are you finding yourself
um using a lot of overtime with
employees is that increased in
particular areas yes
and one other question are employees are
there any employees that are sort of
cross-trained
so that one division
isn't down as many people as another
division is down to where they're
crippled can't do you have some people
who are cross-trained so they can go
back and forth yes absolutely what you
know it's this is the this is the beauty
of our staff is that we have people that
are willing to step up and help out so
you know we have unwind happening you
know we have to ask people to step up
that maybe they were they they were an
eligibility worker prior and they're
doing something now and they can come in
and help lift the load up a little bit
we're doing that everywhere we can and
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um other than
the burnout for Workforce which I think
we can all understand where that's
coming from are you hearing anything
else about the the culture the work
culture that you're gonna try to Foster
to help retain people are they what else
are the factors if anything or is
burnout it
you know I think the flexibility this
High the hybrid the remote uh work the
telework policy that the state has now
is definitely been a great recruitment
tool people like to have flexibility we
need to trust our staff that they can do
their work and I think the department
has been a leader in telework even
before the policy came out we were doing
it I had done a department-wide policy
so I think people want to feel valued
and they want to know that what they do
makes a difference but they want support
from their supervisor when they want to
work environment that doesn't burn them
out we've heard repeatedly that people
say and and we know we look at
productivity what I I go I talk to
supervisors and I say how do you know
what's working how do you know your
staff how does it working with staff is
they're getting the work's getting done
you know and it's getting done well it's
quality work so we do have touch points
and check in on that but I think work
environment like that makes a difference
too so it doesn't just pay you know it's
like you you come to work and you feel
like you want to come to work because
you're making a difference I don't have
to answer your question
retirements of people who might barely
be eligible to retire but they're just
leaving because of the stress and the
vacancy rate is that happening to you
too I think in the very beginning we saw
a lot of that happen um but it's kind of
it's kind of leveled out a little bit we
always have the projected number of
people that could actually retire and it
never comes to a full hundred percent of
that that's good yeah thank you
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman I apologize for the sun I
attempted to help you out but it seems
to be coming from above I couldn't get
her to scale the wall to take care of
that one
as for the 21
on page uh well your org chart here is
there a way to maybe summarize how that
21 percent would be spread across this
particular org chart of bureaus and
divisions for example five percent in
the dcyf or uh 10 in the division of
Behavioral Health something along that
example we do have uh slides further in
the deck that break that down
specifically if that works that's
Nathan's section
uh representable thank you chairman
um regarding page eight and the
initiatives and goals that you're going
to be bringing up with your staff are
those slides going to come back to us at
some point in a future presentation sure
yep they'll be posted probably on our
website too so yes it'll be public
documents to share can follow up can we
then just tie that to the same page
somehow where this document is so people
can make the tie
um sure right
I I I would look to Kevin for that one
yeah sure anything that comes through
the division this session that's budget
related will post to the division three
um so the to the 21 vacancy rate I just
to make you feel a little bit better by
commiserating Rockingham County uh the
nursing home is like a 45 vacancy rate
so you're doing great
but so perspective so uh you can
continue
and so if there's no other questions on
our sort of our vision our focus at the
next part I think is a natural segue is
representative Moody was asking about
some of the Staffing breakdown if it's
great thank you
on um page nine what we've done here is
we have put together a history at the
agency level of Staffing positions
um I I just want to thank my team for
for manually putting this together
there's quite a bit of work and
Reconciliation that goes into something
like this
um but what you'll what you'll see is
back in 2013
um there were a total of 20 roughly 2
900 full-time authorized positions
um we didn't go back further we looked
further but I honestly couldn't fit it
onto a page and still have it be
um readable but if if you go all the way
back to 2004 the department actually had
36 uh 3 605 positions at that point in
time just if you're looking at it uh
from a 20-year perspective you'll
probably notice uh within division for
children youth and families in the 2020
2021 time period you'll see a large
increase in positions there at that
point in time the legislature
appropriated uh funds and established
positions to address the child
protection system at that point in time
to try to get the case loads down I
believe we had 128 cpsws created at that
point in time
um if you look down towards New
Hampshire hospital also in the 2021 to
2022 time frame
uh you'll see an increase in the number
of New Hampshire hospital positions at
that point in time uh there were
positions that were converted from uh at
that point they were temporary full-time
positions they were converted to
full-time positions uh through through
that particular process
the subsequent page is essentially a
more detailed version at the activity
level of the positions and you'll see a
little bit more movement here and and
some of this is is lateral so if you if
you scroll down to the the ocom section
um if you look at activity 9 500 you'll
see in 2019 to 2020 there's a you know a
roughly a 54 position increase there but
what that actually actually represents
is that's the point in time in which the
financing functions were formally
centralized so what may appear to be a
large increase is actually just a
lateral movement of positions
um yes so the rule of thumb whenever
somebody uses an acronym the first time
I liked it to be set of course and we
got new people here so ocom if I
remember Office of the commissioner this
is sort of the central overhead of the
department yes that that is correct and
I I am also um an individual that does
not enjoy many acronyms I always kick
them back in the GNC letters when I see
them so I will do my best all right to
not do that going forward
um so
where was I
um
right so also in the office of the
commissioner in during that during that
time frame in the in the 20 in the
2019-2020 period you will see a large
increase in 95-20
um that that is legal that's legal and
Regulatory services and that's a that
was at a point in time when we
centralize our child support attorneys
under the central legal services so that
they they were all within the same team
um and then if you look at 9540 where
you see a large you know a decrease of
of over 50 some odd positions that was
actually where we moved positions out of
the office of Information Services into
other areas across the department
um there there are stories in histories
behind each one of those moves
um if if there are questions you know
like in looking at this following up if
you have specific questions
um each one of these will probably take
a little bit of research to get an
answer to but I'm more than willing to
do that if the committee requests that
and thank you representative hole
um is it possible to get these activity
codes with something other than numbers
kind of a general overview of what right
9 400 9500 is and share that with the
committee sure so our and and if if it's
okay with the committee so our plan um
we will be providing a budget briefing
book and and the budget briefing book it
it includes the accounts that are over a
million dollars and um all in all it's
probably close to 200 pages but within
the budget briefing book we have the
activity we have the accounts we have
what are what are the RSA what are the
populations that are being served what
does the service delivery look like is
it a direct service is it a contracted
service will also be incorporating into
that into that document some of the key
performance metrics that that were
either um that were incorporating from
the agency budget request as well as
some of the expected outcomes for each
program and area so I believe that that
document will probably give you more
than more information than you may want
to know but I I believe it should
address all of those questions and and
my My Hope and intention was that the
committee um that we could work from
that document to help have informed
discussions about what are the major
areas you know so we're you know we're
spending time on the 7100 accounts that
are you know 300 million dollars instead
of the fifty thousand dollar account we
may have for some smaller Grant just to
try to just to try to
um make the best use of the committee's
time if if that's appropriate uh that
sounds good other questions I have one
um on
the 9540 line where you're saying we
moved people out of it
um before before my time on finance
uh the kind of the story I had heard was
that there was a budget cycle where it
was really de-prioritized uh and that uh
it and I'm just wondering if if um a
couple things is this is this what we're
seeing going from 2019 to 2020 where the
budget process
de-emphasized I.T and and
um
and also I'm just curious if we have any
lingering negative consequences of
having
um maybe let go a bunch of I.T positions
so we didn't let go of any I.T positions
I was part of the change of this it was
it was during the budget but it was
really driven it was under the time of
commissioner Myers in terms of looking
at how we had structured our our is our
I.T services so it in it in the
department it has toggled back and forth
between being a centralized function and
then being a function that uh puts it
back out into the program area so during
that 19 to 20 time we kept in the ocom
level if you will uh there was
leadership but then we took all of the
I.T folks and put them sitting side by
side with program so that was really
just sort of a going back to what it was
and they stay connected with the
leadership in ocom so for strategy
perspective but for the day-to-day so we
didn't lose anybody
turn to slide uh 11.
um so so the the 21 that we're
referencing earlier that that's that's
actually from from a November
um presentation that we had provided the
most recent figure is before you and it
is it is 20 20.4 as of December
um
the the slide in in front of you this
shows uh a global history of the the
authorized positions full-time
authorized positions and what we've seen
for vacancy rates and so in 2019 you'll
you will see a 12.4 vacancy rate
um average across the department
now there were a number of events that
I'm sure everybody in this room are
aware of uh in in March of 2020 covid
struck in April of 2020 uh all agencies
were put under a hiring freeze until
December of that year
um the the HHS also had a couple of of
unique factors that we were navigating
at the time
um in the 2020-2021 biennium we had a 30
million dollar back of the budget cut
um in this current biennium um we have
had a 22.6 million personnel only uh
back of the budget cut
um and and we had spoken earlier
representative Edwards uh just about the
the 3 000 person cap and how that has
impacted the department
and the cap itself doesn't really do
much from from a from a functions
perspective the the thing that really
has the impact is the 22.6 million
dollar Personnel cut so so what that
meant um I I started my role this past
spring uh so about nine months ago now
and one of the first things that I did
was I said okay division directors each
area you need to hold x million dollars
uh vacant of positions and so
um as was referenced I Believe In the
orientation session uh the the week
prior
um many of dhhs's positions are not 100
generally funded so they're oftentimes a
mix it may be 50 50 maybe 60 40 maybe a
variety
um and any number in between there and
so in order to get to that 22.6 million
dollars we can't it's it's not a
one-to-one we can't take one position
and there's a hundred thousand dollars
we take one position and we get forty
thousand dollars so the um the the
Personnel reduction I think has really
been the the challenging piece because
then we don't even have an opportunity
to post that position
um because you know we'll post a
position and we may need to repost it
and as everybody knows the labor market
right now is is certainly a challenging
one because everybody's asking the
question where did the labor force go
um if anybody has the answer let me know
um and and that is that that continues
to kind of be a challenge and and that's
one of the you know that's one of the
contributing factors to this sort of
exponential growth that you have seen of
course as has already been noted
um 2020 2021 2022 uh presented some
unprecedented challenges for the
department and and perhaps I'd also like
to point out that the department doesn't
work alone and I'll be talking a little
bit about this later we also rely on our
on our community providers and our
contractors in the community and they
face the same challenges that we did it
which only compounded
um
many of the the resource limitations
that we did have at that point
the the subsequent slide on page 12
um there was a request for for a
breakdown of of a part-time
um temporary positions and full-time
temporary positions and this slide here
this this shows you the the temporary
the part-time average of the part-time
temporary positions the department
um we we do utilize these in order to
flex so to speak so when we have a
particular need in a particular area we
try to bring in part-time employees in
lieu of overtime
um to avoid some of those some of those
cultural issues you know whether it be
burnout or otherwise so we do use these
as you see
um more than half of those are currently
vacant
um and and that that's that's kind of a
baseline Trend that you see across those
five years the the next slide on pay on
page 13 this is the average full-time
temporary employees
um I think it's important to point out
that currently in the state fiscal year
101 of those employees are at public
health and a lot of that does have to do
with the ELC and arpa funds and other
funds that what's that oh I I apologize
the um
[Music]
now
um
where was I
yes I was on an acronym again I
apologize all right just just throw the
gavel at me next time I do that
oh that works too
um
so we do have 101 part-time Temporaries
employees at Public Health right now
included in that number as well are the
um I'm sorry full-time included in that
number as well are the the new positions
at Hampstead Hospital
um Hampstead Hospital as as you all know
uh was was acquired by the state this
past June I believe it's the first time
the state has ever required a hospital
so those positions did not end up being
as full-time authorized positions at
this point in time that would be the
Department's intent through this budget
to have those converted to full-time
authorized positions but those are also
showing up in those figures there
on page 14
um these are the unclassified positions
at the Department of Health and Human
Services and
[Music]
um
you will see a slight increase in 2023
and the total number
um that represents the six unclassified
positions that were created at Hampstead
Hospital those represent the executive
team yes representative Edwards uh okay
I I I'm going to ask you occasionally to
do a little bit of a tangent because
half half of the committee is new and I
don't know what they know and what they
don't know and then I have a really bad
memory so so earlier you mentioned back
of the budget cuts I think that's an
important concept we could come back and
maybe you could teach us what that means
how that that works of course I don't
think everyone knows and then you you
know just in this the reason I I stopped
you here was just to help people
understand the distinction between
unclassified and classifieds because
these could be new terminologies
absolutely
um so
if you'd like to I'm more than happy to
all right so classified employees
um are are primarily are primarily
regulated by the Personnel system so the
division of personnel
um they have Personnel rules classified
employees
um uh may be represented by the union
the unclassified employees are
established under RSA 941a
the classified employees are under a
separate pay scale which you can find on
the department of administrative
services website and
um
versus the unclassified employees which
you will find in RSA 941a there is a
schedule there the unclassified
positions for most agencies are
established in their respective RSA uh
the the department
dhhs's employees will you will also find
those in the RSA there there are some
some slight differences between them
though but unclassified employees uh
they they do not receive overtime
um they often myself I I am an
unclassified employee so I will work
until things get done versus classified
employees
um who who you know would receive
overtime or comp time if if they worked
outside of their standard 37.5 or 40
Hour Week depending on the position does
it also work to think of it as just
um salaried versus hourly I think that's
okay so if there are no questions I
think representative Holt has a question
and then representative Stringham
so sorry I'm coming at this from the
corporate world a little bit am I to
read this chart on page 14 that there
are effectively 93
positions within the HHS completely 10
of which are currently unfilled
that our salaried and the balance of the
workers of the 2900 are all hour hourly
these things yes yes so the 83 of the
positions are are currently filled are
in the process of being filled and then
the the head not answered it which is
the balance of the the 2800 remaining
positions are all hourly yes correct uh
representative stream
um this is kind of uh flipping your
point about cutting a position and then
essentially losing Grant support
um in terms of any census uh driven
grants
um
um either due to failure to provide
services that um
for for services and for people that are
identified or an inability to census
them uh because we're short staffed do
you see see the current shortfall is
limiting us and uh essentially reducing
our access to say federal grants does
that make any
so so the
so so what you're saying is if if we
have vacant positions
um are we are we unable to leverage all
federal funds available to us
uh that that's that's part of it okay
so the
I
so if we if we don't have positions
filled
um there are a variety of things that
could happen and I'm partially going to
be answering representative norgren's
question as well here from earlier if if
we have vacant positions
and you know we are not able to whether
it's respond or write to no requests or
respond to to court orders or
um be be timely with requests of the
legislature or whatever it may be you
know those those are not necessary those
may not necessarily have any media
dollar impact however if we do receive
grants or Appropriations through the
legislature in general funds or whatever
other funding source
um there is a process that we often have
to go through in order to get those
funds out the door
um all of our funds above ten thousand
dollars if they're not sole source they
have to go through an objective uh
procurement process which is timely and
intensive every award has to be awarded
um based on objective criteria published
and known to all parties uh part of its
establishment or RSA 21i and part of
it's under uh RSA 21g36 and 37.
um
and then and then all those would need
to subsequently be approved by GNC so if
if we do not have Staffing available to
conduct the planning to prepare the RFP
to conduct the evaluation and then
manage the subsequent contract those
Grant funds or those General funds or
whatever funds they may be may not
actually be spent
um am I
getting to your
yeah that's one one example okay yes
but are you also asking if the work
doesn't get done like what's the impact
of the work not getting done well I'm
sure it doesn't support your mission
very well but I was also interested in
the financial side yeah
foreign
I think we have a lot of overtime in
some of those cases as well thank you
so so are there other questions at this
point okay when you think it's a a good
break to go back
um we did two back of the budget cuts I
think in uh the last budget we did one
on Manpower head count of limiting uh
you to three thousand
full-time
classified positions do they say that
right yes yes uh or unclassified
positions classified okay and we also
did a dollar back of a budget and so be
again because we have four new people on
finance what is it back of the uh budget
cut and and what and what impact do you
think that had sure absolutely so
um when when House Bill won the
operating budget and House Bill 2
um the trailer Bill are passed there is
a surplus statement that accompanies
those bills and it it effectively shows
here's our expenditures here's our
revenue for House Bill one
simplistically put for House Bill 2
there may be a variety of Appropriations
or assumptions within that and so it may
be a six million dollar appropriation
for this purpose it may be a you know
we're going to assume we're going to
increase our Revenue by one million
dollars at dra if we hire new
collections officers and there's a
listing there there's a series of pages
that tie into that and and then that
comes up with a total
um what what is also included in there
is if there is a back of the budget cut
so let's say the department you're given
a three billion dollar budget
however you are now required to return
30 million dollars of General funds and
how we do that during the biennium is we
either hold positions vacant in order to
hit that to to address those General
funds uh certain contracts may not go
forward certain initiatives that or
funded may not go forward some of which
may make her naturally just due to
limitations of resources some of which
may occur intentionally and so the broad
back of the budget cut that that could
be addressed through contract lapses or
or position lapses and whatnot
versus the current biennium has a 22.6
million dollar Personnel back of the
budget cut and that must be satisfied
exclusively you know with with the class
10 or Class 12 or class 50 or class 59
um Personnel lines
and how that has really played out in
practice is is we
from a hiring perspective
if we have
um you know say we have 10 positions in
a particular area and five of those are
filled and we're only able to post three
of those
and we're not going to be posting the
other two that I mean it's essentially
what that means is we will never have an
opportunity to fill those other two
positions the other three positions
given the current labor market we may be
able to hire somebody within a month we
may be able to be able to hire somebody
within seven months and then we bring
them in and then uh to the
commissioner's Point earlier if if you
bring somebody in but then you lose them
I mean that that is a critical function
long story short those two positions
that we can never post will will
continue to remain vacant and those
three that we can post we will never
have a hundred percent
um vacancy rate necessary well and I'm
thinking globally here take three and
move to 3 000.
um we will never we will never have a
hundred percent so because of that
because the dollars really Drive what
we're able to actually hire the three
thousand dollar cap I mean it could be
thirty one hundred
uh I'm I'm yes three three thousand
first
there we go the 3 000 person cap really
doesn't I I mean it's it is it of course
a requirement which we have adhered to
but but it's it's the dollars that are
really driving what is what is possible
uh from a hiring perspective and so
that's you know that that's why um as of
December we we didn't quite have 2600
employees and we were still 400 people
off one of the many reasons but one of
the reasons why we were still 400
employees off of that cap
I think thank you for that um
representative Holt
so going to your analogy using 10 people
right five positions filled sure five
open right you can post three
so I didn't read through hb1 and hb2
last year I was not a House member but
why would it not be possible to post
the three positions that you're talking
about posting plus the other two and
then as soon as you have the three
filled right then put the freeze in
place so you have five openings you're
trying to look for people and as you
ramp up toward that you get the first
position filled you get the second
position filled why not
then start looking at closing those
positions or putting a hold on them
instead of putting hold out outright so
it's for certain positions we we
actually conduct Mass postings where
where we post more of the the the the
the position in general you know where
we have 30 positions
um and and we do exactly that for those
types of scenarios for other scenarios
where you know there's there's a
business systems analyst and there's a
program specialist and there's another
position in order to manage
um in order to manage the back of the
budget cut we've had to unfund those
positions and so
um there's a little bit of behind the
scenes work where we we don't we we
can't post those positions that don't
have dollars tied to them because in the
system there's just some challenges so
we we try to address it the best that we
can but there are some system
limitations
um that that we just have to manage on
an ongoing basis
it's a great question though
all right uh thank you for that uh I
don't see any other questions we we left
where you were about to plunge into 15.
okay uh let me let me do a time check
we're about an hour into this when you
were thinking about this presentation
how long did you think it was going to
take us to get to this point 20 minutes
something like that something like that
the commissioner's shaking her head
longer or shorter
we're hoping for the whole thing would
be about it yeah we were aiming for
about an hour hour and a half yeah oh
okay all right very good
the the next
um
if you turn to slide 15
um and slide 16. so a few years ago the
department had an external consulting
firm conduct an analysis of the
Department's overall operations I I
pulled a couple of Snippets
um just and and the full report is
online I can certainly provide the link
to that I Source it at the bottom
um I pulled a couple of Snippets from
that report where they were looking at
the total number of positions at the
department compared to states of a
similar size
um just to kind of because there were a
couple of questions around whether HHS
is is lean or is it bloated from a
position perspective and we were talking
earlier just about how the department is
about 45 of the entire state budget
um but but we represent about 3 200 of
the 11
000 employees uh in in the current
agency budget
um which I believe is a little less than
29 right around 29 and and so what you
would you see on slide 15 this is the
entire department compared to other
states and and the the graph on the left
is the is the per 100 000 retina the per
capita comparison
um the report also includes a more
specific
um analysis of Public Health departments
uh from across the country now I I think
it's also just important to recognize
that every state has a different model
so some may rely more on subcontractors
or contractors and I think that's just
important to recognize when looking at
this
um one kind of thing that just stands
out to me and perhaps I'm biased is the
um the public health spend per staffer
which is 438 000 for New Hampshire Which
is higher than some of the other
comparisons that they had included in
that but but that that report is
available online if if anyone is is
curious
um or would like to investigate that
further
so I'll come to you in just a second so
so this is a measure of potential
efficiency so if we're talking about uh
quality or Effectiveness do we have any
sort of Benchmark to to be coupled with
this like do we know we're doing at
least as well as Vermont for example
and we we can't really tell that right
well I I think you'd have to look at it
at a program specific level so if you
were going to look at like Medicaid or
something along those lines you know
there may be and I think that would be a
further
further extensive analysis to really get
to that question about how to do that
comparison I don't believe there was any
similar type comparison as far as
program outcomes
um in that report though
thank you representative Hull thank you
so it's not clear to me whether these
other states have such a high dependency
on county level operations right I'm
assuming the county level nursing homes
and any other things that are happening
within the counties and or even the
major cities are not rolling up to the
state level in this graph where Vermont
might count their personnel differently
for instance do you know
right being in this being in this field
for a while do you know whether Vermont
for instance or mean
um does their roll up differently in
terms of total Personnel I I'm not aware
of how the the county systems and the
other states included here operate but
but to representative Edwards point this
is one indicator and there's many that
on slide 17
um yes
um it looked like commissioner wanted to
say something and then we have
Representatives verified
I was just going to respond in terms of
the county question I know that Vermont
New Hampshire Maine and Rhode Island
don't are we're very similar in how we
doesn't
um with the county structure and how we
do our state funding I can't speak to
Wyoming and Montana but I believe it's
the same I think we were trying to look
at governments that operated similar to
our state
thank you representative could you
explain how the graph on the right ties
to the left it goes from zero to 80 and
the numbers are you don't even don't
don't correlate
are you on um page 16
yes so so that that's the the staff per
100 000 residents
yes
of course
slide 17
um
one thing that I think is important just
before we start to get into the actual
budget here in the coming weeks
um you will see contract lines in our
budget um some of which are large
I like to think about the contracts that
we have with our providers in two
distinct ways I like to think about the
contractors that provide Direct Services
to the Department
versus the the contractors that provide
services on behalf of the department to
the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire we have a we have a little
over 200 contractors that are providing
Services I've listed some examples here
given the time I won't go through each
one of those
on page 18 you will see examples of the
contractors that deliver services to New
Hampshire citizens on behalf of the
department there are more of those
there's there's over 400 the department
at any point in time may have 800 to
1000 active agreements
um there are a variety of different
agreements uh types that we have
um but for the purposes of this I just
wanted to draw that out just to kind of
show how how large of a portfolio the
department does have with contractors
um
now because of that the department has
has seen contractors and the Contracting
process the procurement process as
critically important to our success
um back in 2018 we were receiving
complaints from the vendor Community the
Contracting process was taking too long
some of the contracts
um were taking a year and a half to get
out which was which was Far Below which
was Far Beyond acceptable
um the the leadership team at that point
in time devoted a considerable focus and
resources to making the process better
so on page 19 you will see back in 2018
we did Implement a lean Six Sigma demeic
it's you it's a process whereby you
define what you're doing you establish
the system to measure what you're doing
then you begin to assess what are the
results of that and then you make
improvements to your system and then you
control for those improvements and and
that has led to a variety of really
really positive improvements our
processing time in 2018 was 140 142 days
from start to finish it's now at 94 days
and many of those outliers where things
were taking a year and a half are now
generally a thing of the past
um we and I I won't go through through
each one of these details given the time
but long story short we've made I.T
um we've Incorporated I.T Solutions uh
DocuSign
e-signature that has taken a process
that took weeks I think the fastest
we've cut it down to is 27 days where we
sign base sign and the AG approves it's
pretty incredible the changes that have
been made on that we're currently in the
process of rolling out a contract life
cycle management system that will
further accelerate the creation of the
rfps which historically have been email
based which is a really bad way to work
on a document when 12 people need to be
involved and then lastly the
commissioner earlier did mention the
smart sheets application we're also
incorporating that to get out of excel
which is inherently risk prone from my
perspective and manual to implement
Implement a smartsheet solution which
will further automate
um that and Meredith is here to talk
about the the contents on on page 20
relative to contracts quality management
and the role that her team is going to
be playing in that going forward
before welcome uh before you get into
that uh this is sort of a commissioner
question maybe as I think about
um your your management environment and
and the importance of these 400 plus
contractors are to getting the job done
it it feels to me like there's a whole
lot of Goo that you have to Wade through
in order to actually get direct contact
with what's going on
um and goo is not a an acronym but but
uh I I I'm just I I would like to have a
conversation with you at some point
about how Nimble you think all of this
is given given the amount that we rely
on these contractors this really I think
inherently needs to be a very Nimble
process for you to be able to articulate
needs look for the responses select
engage and then if need be you know
terminate and I'm and and and so that's
a lot that you're not prepared to talk
about I don't think but you know
actually could respond I don't I don't
know can you hear me without the
microphone you need a microphone for the
public
so goo the
I think I think it's government
operations or something okay I'll go
with that
um that first bubble that I was talking
about um the quality piece that that so
I just want to give credit Nathan um in
2018 was leading our contracts unit and
his charge was to streamline and make
efficient and all these processes and
he's done a great job and the person
that is in the position now has done a
great job so in terms of we narrowed
down the goo we have a better angle on
it and this this focus in on uh the the
contracts and the monitoring is going to
be the focus for this year so in terms
of system streamline we've made a lot of
gains I've been there a long time I've
never seen it as Nimble as it is now for
us to be able to say that we can cut it
down from 141 to high 90s is amazing and
we can cut it down a little bit more
from there so we can get better how we
execute but we also can get better at
how we measure outcomes and and impacts
does that answer that's a great answer I
I I'm just I'm just sort of thinking of
the of the negative aspect of this uh do
you do you do you believe you have a
enough metrics to uh and tools uh and um
public support to terminate contracts
because you know taking somebody's money
away can be painful so so I'm just
curious if if uh if you find yourself
really empowered to let contractors go
when you think the time has come
yeah I mean I guess I guess there's the
angle of terminating the contractor or
working with the contractor to get it
right
um you know we have the ability to
terminate contracts we have um but that
comes at a cost right so not just a
financial cost but a cost of who's no
longer suddenly receiving their services
and filling that Gap and then trying to
find somebody so I hear what you're
saying but I also would like to look at
it that can we improve who we have doing
what they're doing so that they can that
they can be meeting the expectations but
we always have that if we need to pull
that lever
yeah thank you I I just find that 400
plus daunting but
that's why you're doing it we've got a
rhythm we're in a we're in a hum right
now with in terms of how we've
structured our um our contracts teams
how they I mean just from the whole
review it's I'm Gonna Knock on Wood
because I don't want it to to jinx it
but we're we're in a decent operational
a question to uh representative walner
thank you
um I think that the 400 contractors are
of course are helping you
you know to succeed at the mission of
the department and what are you hearing
from them I wondered I doubt that you
have this but do you have any idea how
many employees these 400 contractors
have totally and what are you hearing
from the field out there about their
ability to hire and their vacancy rates
yeah interestingly enough right before
this I was speaking with a group of
Center for non-profits and their
Workforce is about 15 of of the
workforce in the state right and they're
doing our business right so the things
that we can't we can't do and they're
struggling as well so we were really
talking about how do we complement
resources and not compete how do we work
together to fill that pipe how do we
unclog this system
right that's a that's bigger than any
one
um thing
um and and the challenges that they have
with our Contracting we talked a lot
about that in terms of you know the
improvements we've made but what else
can we be doing as well to make it
easier for them to be able to be nimble
I just wondered in your meeting with the
non-profits did they talk about their
Workforce I mean what kinds of
percentages uh
Workforce are they down
um they didn't give me a number
specifically
um I I think we know from the work that
we do that when we can't put people in
placements because they don't have the
staff but I didn't get a specific number
thank you
any other questions
welcome Miss Meredith tell us I'm going
to work on your last name
t-e-l-u-s-u-s and the ooh pretend it has
an um so it's like goo it's oh good I
know that you got it and I I think
government organization
if I had to do the acronym that's what
I'm coming up
thank you it's our goo that we work in
every day good morning everyone my name
is Meredith Telus I'm the director of
our division of program quality and
integrity for the department and I
wanted to talk to you this morning a
little bit about our contracts quality
management unit which is a newly stood
up unit and also uh broadly just discuss
kind of metrics at the department and
specifically
um uh direct you to Form B which is
something representative Edwards and I
have discussed on a couple occasions so
uh first slide slide 20.
uh is to discuss our contracts quality
management unit so our division is is
relatively new in terms of the structure
of the department we were stood up right
before covid started so
um that was an interesting experience
many functions within the division
already existed this was just an
opportunity to bring them together to do
things simultaneously so a lot of
internal and external audit a lot of
quality review a lot of performance
evaluation program evaluation kind of
metrics
um all just sort of coming together at
once had been being done already but
this was a chance to bring them together
and then building off of the work that
had been done in the contracts unit over
the course of 2020
um about a year ago or so the former
commissioner commissioner shimanet with
the direction from then Deputy
Commissioner Weaver
um said we we want to stand up a
particular function within the division
that can just work on contracts quality
management and so it's the focus of this
unit really is
um on the 400 contractors that are
delivering services to the citizens so
from the former two slides that you saw
where there are some contractors that
deliver Services sort of to us and then
there are others that deliver to the
citizens it's the ones to the citizens
that were particularly focused on for
this unit and we managed to identify and
fund a couple of positions so it's a
two-person unit just to be clear it's
not a gigantic unit and the thrust of it
really is to
um sort of track and evaluate the
quality of the services that are being
provided so as you can imagine
with only two people they are not
tracking and evaluating the quality of
400 contracts that's not how it's set up
the focus of it is that we're going to
set up uh the tools and the systems that
can be used across all of our individual
program areas who are the contract
owners for these 400 contracts and then
there are going to be some contracts
that we want to delve into more closely
meaning that the unit will be able to
really work hand in hand with those
program areas on their specific
contracts so Step One is sort of to
develop a tool so that we can evaluate
which of our contracts have a higher
strategic impact and those are the ones
that that we will step in and kind of
really work with people on and then and
then develop other just generic contract
management tools that we can hand over
to program areas and say here you might
want to use this from our strategic
Impact Tool it looks like this has a
medium strategic impact therefore we
would suggest do you utilize these
particular tools guidelines best
practices whatever it is to help you
manage this contract more on your own
so I I want to really emphasize that
contract management is happening now
across the department in every program
area on every contract it's already
happening
but the people who do the contract
management today are program area
Specialists right they're subject matter
experts in that program so it might be
it might be um an sud recovery service
and the person who's managing that
contract knows everything about sud
recovery they know the Clinical Services
that they intend to get provided they
know the they know the provider they
know the beneficiaries they know what
they want it to look like but they're
not necessarily a subject matter in
contract management that the there are
best practices in contract management
that you can study and get good at
that's not their area of expertise so
the focus of this unit is for us to have
that expertise and be able to work with
them to help them get better at managing
the contracts
hopefully that makes sense so
strengthening the standardized process
for contract management is sort of one
of our short-term goals that we've
already been working on in developing
those tools
but when we talked about contract
contract management that's really the
the middle section of owning a contract
right so you execute the contract
everybody signed it I said I want these
services from you you said yep I'll do
it and then I need to have some system
where I'm evaluating whether or not
you're doing it and that's this is the
middle section until until we close out
that contract that's what's happening
there
long term we're going to get to contract
life cycle management that's where we're
going from here and contract life cycle
management is literally you can picture
like one of those circles I should have
put a graphic on the page but picture
one of those circles that has you know a
bunch of arrows at all point the same
direction or you can picture a snake
eating its tail whatever graphic works
for you but picture something that's in
a circle and what you do is start
starting kind of at the beginning right
there's a there's a service or a
delivery that's like you know a twinkle
in someone's eye we would be able to sit
with that person in that program area
and say how does this align with your
strategic goals
and then come up with okay we understand
how it aligns with your strategic goals
now you're going to enter into the
contract for these Services what are the
metrics that you're going to gather
what's the data that this contractor is
going to report to you or that you're
going to get from some other data source
what are you going to get to show you
whether or not this contract is doing
those things I feel a question coming on
yeah I you know because I don't really
know how many people you have to do this
and you just said something I think
that's really important is you're you're
engaging I assume you consider the
program managers like clients internal
clients uh you're engaging your internal
clients before they've issued an RFP
well before that you're helping them
clarify the Strategic goals and and what
the metrics are and you're big you're
able to embed that I'm guessing then
therefore in the RFP as a as a set of
requirements that's the goal we're not
there yet but yes that's where we want
to go
how good are you at that I mean are you
are you getting like the top 20 percent
really big contracts you get in the top
80 you know I I'm it's not even a
question you could should be asked but I
I am just curious
because we talked about this is what is
your 10-year plan are you going to get
to that to where you you feel like
you've got the resourcing and
integration with the management so that
in 10 years from now we've got you know
great contract metrics we got great
internal Department metrics we've got a
review and evaluation you know I I we're
in year three of of you growing your
capability so I'm just trying to
understand you know kind of where we're
at and what the coming attractions are
and and what we need to be thinking in
order to get to where we may really want
to be yep so a couple things one is that
as the commissioner mentioned one of her
commitments is to sort of work to
elevate this part of the department so
we will have that strategic Direction as
a department and we will be able to work
more closely with the program areas
to accomplish that as far as the metrics
go I mean data is always the issue right
it's it takes an enormous amount of work
to get
clean data
that is that is
um relevant to the task at hand and
actionable and that's why you really
want to have I have the two people to
answer your question on that so I have
two
um and to be able to have those
conversations with the program areas
pre-rfp that's really the hurdle is
being able to to say we need to pause
here and have this conversation so that
we can make sure that as you enter the
RFP and you enter into a contract we've
got data that's meaningful behind it
that is a big lift it really is but we
have a lot of strategy Direction headed
that way
um I will say you asked earlier kind of
the impact of the back of the budget cut
one of the impacts from my division's
perspective is it's it can be difficult
to get the attention of the program
areas when they need to be working on
their day-to-day so fully then we kind
of say well we have to slow down this
contract process so that we can have
this conversation that but it's
proactive but those proactive things can
kind of get put to the side while people
need to get through the day and get
contract signed so they can get Services
delivered
do you have a representative from the
I.T community that sits in with you on
those pre-rfp meetings to help you
figure out how to efficiently get at
some of that data so we're not at the
point yet where we're really doing the
pre-rfp phase right now we're working on
the contract management phase but we
will shift forward so that working on
the pre-i pre-rfp phase and I'll let
Nathan answer your question and and um
there there is a fairly robust
um process that occurs right now uh to
summarize very quickly basically an area
of the department they put in a request
to our centralized contracts team they
answer a series of questions relative to
risky whether it's privacy security what
type of procurement do they expect what
type of services are delivered
anticipated delivery date dollar amount
and then there's a kickoff meeting where
we invite the appropriate party so we
invite privacy security we invite
project management if it's particularly
complex we may invite particular
attorneys from a certain area if that
requires it and there's an initial
planning meeting from which the whole
project then moves forward because there
may be anywhere from five to up to 15
people involved in any particular
request for proposal depending upon the
complexity
okay I'm just for those of you on the
committee who are going oh this has got
nothing to do with Finance it's almost
the point right that we're meeting
before the numbers are released uh what
what I'm I'm trying to understand is the
connection between our responsibility to
provide appropriate levels of Manpower
and money to the mission and and what
the impact or the you know when we turn
over those resources
how that gets generated into actual
services for the state so so that's
where that's the conversation we're
having now if you're wondering why we're
not talking about money
so the follow-up to the RFP phase and
identifying what what data matters what
metrics are actually going to help you
measure this contract and then
implementing it into a contract you then
are trying to manage to that data you're
getting reports out of it and the tail
end of a contract ideally is that you
can you know within the within the
course of the life of the contract
you're managing the contractor with that
information but you're simultaneously
looking at whether or not it actually
that contract that strategy that you've
employed and using that contract is
getting you closer to your goals or is
it not and that's when you'd say we may
need to change this contract we may need
to amend it or we need to change our
strategy entirely and that's the back
end of the cycle so then you get to
redirect the way that you're doing the
services entirely or or just tweak it
whatever the data is showing you you get
to make some data-driven decisions
around that and then you start the
process again
so that would be the contract life cycle
yep with that slide another I think
that's your last slide slide one more
like 21. this is important this is where
you're going to give us a tutorial
so
poor public health is Christian
School sorry
um I selected act completely at random a
Form B just to put onto the
um slide deck so that you could see what
it is
um Form B is a section of the agency
budget submission that that identifies
activity level goals and performance
metrics and it's just an area that the
department will every every agency every
Department in state government
identifies specific goals specific
outputs and outcomes and then sets a
Target and then identifies for the
coming biennium the the so this would be
24 and 25 goals for that particular
measure whatever it is so in this case
it's the um uh Bureau of laboratory
services is what it is and I just wanted
this on here as an illustration for the
committee members so that you could see
what this is and how it works and that
it's available in the agency budget
submission which is online
part of our very large uh budget
submission but it's done at the at the
activity level
so so one thing I I'd be interested in
it when we get down to this level
is
um do we have what what is our statutory
requirement for for doing this is this a
federal statute that we're complying
with or a state RSA or state RSA well I
mean in this example but just in general
oh I I I I I would want to know okay or
is this is this a federal program a
state federal program or uh for those
that don't know the commissioner
exercises some discretion on creating
programs that don't necessarily have
statutory backup and so
I I think there's some discretion that
the commissioner has to establish a
program that is not
backed up by an RSA or federal
requirement directly
I
so I knew still I think she has an
answer if you're looking for a Lifeline
sure and and I think this may be where
the budget briefing book will help a lot
because every every account that we have
in that document has an RSA or or
authorizing statute or federal directive
or otherwise attached to that so so as
we go through that process we'll be able
to tie each one of those to a specific
RSA outstanding and so what I think you
just gently told me is that there are no
programs that we're going to review that
so one example
would be and there
would be this contracts quality
management unit for example that is
something that the commissioner decided
the former commissioner and the current
commissioner decided to do because they
believed that it was necessary in order
to enact all of the other requirements
that we have
all right and I'm I'm just saying that
for context I just want to understand
what we're doing why we're doing it and
not not that I'm looking for things to
kill in case anyone's curious so that
but I think that's helpful so you're
saying in the form B it would be helpful
to identify whether or not the
goals outlined the targets and
objectives outlined are federal versus
State versus discretionary I you know
that's kind of stuff I think about but I
think to Mr White's point that that
information is in the briefing book and
I I I could cross reference it pretty
easily I think and and in the agency
budget it's also in the form a that
precedes the Form B
okay and so I I have a really bad memory
because everything was a blur last time
we went through this were these were
these form bees a regular and this is a
miserable question were these form bees
a regular part of what we reviewed as we
went trijin and marching through the
budget data no I don't think so you
so I'm thinking I would like to see
these as we actually get into the
governor's budget request process is is
that an easy to share with us when we're
talking your budget so yes and no so
what what I was proposing and and maybe
I can share an example with a committee
is with our budget briefing book once we
have the governor's figures we'll have
the RSA we'll have the program we'll
have the outcomes of the population
serve delivery service we'll also have
the the accounting information for that
specific account but what what my plan
is right now we've been devising or
maybe that sounds a little too uh
surreptitious what we've been developing
sorry well we've been developing where
yeah we're up to something but
um what we've been developing is key
metrics for that particular area that we
plan on lifting from the agency budget
to put it into that document because
because I I just don't I I don't want to
create
um additional work or or confusion where
are switching from the agency budget
request which is going to have different
dollar figures potentially than the
governor's budget and and and then and
then shifting over to the budget
briefing book so so my goal is to try to
get all that into a single location for
for the committee to to make the work as
effective as possible see oh that sounds
good and in my simple way I thought okay
these form B's are already done and I
was trying to find a way to repurpose
work to make us smarter while we're
doing it that's what my objective was
the challenge is that they're within a
2000 page document and we'd have to pull
them out from from this section and that
section or we just have to go through
them and reference page 743 when we come
to a particular account so I'll I'll
defer to the committee on on on what you
would prefer my My Hope was to have that
representative Northern you've chaired
this committee before do you do you have
any thoughts on the extent to which we
want to have these form bees
um readily accessible as we're going
through the agency budgets or
because right now you go read them I
think it'll keep you up all night
so I mean they're already there I mean
maybe when you appear in front of us you
can reference the number I think most of
us are using
some technology we could we could find
them if we wanted to to reference them
they're currently posted in the agency
budget submission
which is on the Das website if not the
Gen also the general court website you
have a question representable thank you
chairman so
at a high level and whether it's
internal staff or contracts
um
what are you guys using As the metric
for
is are we actually hitting the objective
at the highest level Our Lives being
saved is someone living longer what is
the foundation for this that you look
back to to say yes we've done something
right we've
pick on any Department right Elder Care
Services right we're seeing that
patients are living longer
what are you using and how do we look at
that information so we have data and
metrics all across the department it
is my division owns some of it largely
related to Medicaid dcyf has their own
data Public Health has a whole Bureau
for data it is literally all over the
department all of our federal grants
require all kinds of data and
performance reporting in addition to the
financial reporting that they do so that
exists and it's reported on on a regular
basis and it's reviewed in terms of the
the outcomes that we're getting to
one of the challenges is that as as we
look at the budget so let me have I'll
answer your question in two parts one of
the challenges is that as we look at the
budget that data does not necessarily
cleanly align with the way the budget is
split up because it doesn't right
because programs cross areas Medicaid is
a perfect example of this Medicaid
exists all over the department everyone
in the department is working to keep the
Medicaid train going the direction we
want it to go so there are metrics
related to Medicaid that we have a whole
website our mqis Medicaid quality
information system website tells you all
kinds of metrics related to how well the
Medicaid population is doing in the
state but I can't tie that cleanly just
into the Medicaid accounting unit
because
six different divisions are working on
those metrics and working with our mcos
and working with our providers to make
it work so that's that's one thing
another thing I just want to mention is
that there are metrics that tell us how
well the population is doing right our
population Health outcomes and those are
the things we all really care about are
people dying at a younger age are people
um um quitting tobacco are they
um or at prenatal care is another good
example
um so we can look at that I mean with
the Medicaid population we have a little
more ownership over it but for a lot of
population Health outcomes the
department doesn't own the whole
population right we own individual
programs and we work with other people
to make those programs effective so it
but it's dependent on community level
providers it's dependent on the
education system it's dependent on local
state and the police and fire and at a
community level you're all working
together to make a single population
Health outcome work or not work so we do
collect those things but they don't they
don't always align exactly to the budget
they don't always align exactly to your
contract and so that's where we kind of
break it down a little bit into smaller
chunks so that we can measure whether or
not a program is working or a contract
is working
that's a long-winded answer to your
question but
I hope it helps I think the takeaway is
by year 10 you'll have all those things
aligned figure it out we're on our way
okay so are you done with your prepared
remarks I I I I I still would like to
see you know your we're year three of a
10-year plan what what what are the
Coming Attractions I'd like to see that
so I think one thing that will happen is
as we move into the budget the the
commissioner will be able to come back
and provide her broader
um commitments area and the deliverables
associated with those and we'll be
looking at those and how they align from
the Department level down into the
divisions down into the activities down
into our contracts and how can we get
these things to kind of cascade upward
and downward in a way that when we
prepare metrics for you all for our for
our budget or for public consumption it
it is aligned and you can sort of
measure that okay thank you do you think
we're we're done with your section here
so we hit positions metric Works do you
because those were all together in on my
sheet
the the the question of the um the the
potential salary increases for state
employees yeah I mean I see oh I see is
a bullet that under HHS uh a road map
the third bullet was salary do you want
to tell me what that was Mr Ripple do
you know what that means
you did your initial request of the
department did have to do with the
potential increase in salary for state
employees or any uh hiring and retention
bonuses that HHS might do and where the
money for those things might come from
right and so it doesn't seem like that's
right for today then because the state
plan overall is not in place and you're
only 29 of that plan anyways right so
you're waiting I I think it may be a
more fruitful discussion after February
14th November's budget comes out so so
that's a good question uh when the
governor gives his uh Speech To Us in
the House of Representatives
um
representative Hall what when will we be
able to have our first division three
meeting
15th or more 16th excuse me February
15th the 15th of February 16th
you can get started right away I don't
believe a full committee meeting has
been held yet so typically as soon as
the governor's budget comes out uh the
governor and his budget director will
come and present to the full finance
committee and then the divisions will
break up and start meeting I don't
believe that initial meeting has been
scheduled yet but
assuming is scheduled in the near future
I think you could start meeting
soon after the 15th okay because because
we should start scheduling that or at
least pencil in it in oh oh I'll see if
I can talk to the finance Vice chair
about that that meeting so uh all right
um I think what we ought to do now is
because if anyone who wants to go to the
cafeteria they may shut down at one I'm
proposing we recess let people go get
something to eat clear their head a
little bit and come back at 110
does that how does that sound do you
representative Northern take about a 30
the rest of the plan for the afternoon
is uh I believe we're going to hear from
Ms Tilly on public health we're going to
hear from somebody else on the Hampstead
Hospital
those were uh we we were referencing uh
Mr Ripple's email of uh
31 January that he forward that to us
so we have we still have some some
you're okay okay so uh Miss uh
representative Hall is there a sequence
for the events this afternoon in terms
of which presentations at what time or
at least in what which order
the the the the
that's a good point it indicates that
Hampstead Hospital is expecting to go at
one o'clock I'm proposing that we start
more like 110 and and then the public
health said 130 or two okay so I think
they did that hoping that we'd not spend
a lot of time talking so
thank you okay all right uh with that uh
all right it's uh it's 1 14. I think we
have a quorum I think representative
nordgren is probably just around the
corner and she'll show up any moment so
so at 1 15 I'm going to call this out a
division three out of recess
and I think uh next in the lineup is uh
is uh the folks from Hampstead Hospital
so come on up and even before you get
going let me just uh check with Mr
Ripple do you do you have anything for
the good of the committee before we get
rolling I don't okay all right thank you
hi
welcome
okay
okay so I'm Kathleen Collins I'm the CEO
of Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility and uh thank you for
having us here today we appreciate being
able to give you an overview of
Hampstead Hospital
hi I'm Sean qualter I'm the CFO at
Hampstead Hospital thank you for having
me
so so what you didn't say maybe you were
just about to is
um because the state has taken over
Hampstead fairly recently you know could
you could you also make sure we
understand your longevity your record
28 years
so I'm a long-standing member of
Hampstead Hospital's uh Community
um
I was the CEO at Hampstead Hospital
prior to the the state taking over and I
worked there as a counselor for many
many years moved up into unit management
and then also decided that I wanted to
take things into a more business side of
things and started working in
administration and working towards that
and I will let you give
yes so I um I started in uh late August
so I've been here about five months at
Hampstead previously I was um executive
director
um uh for Genesis HealthCare and uh
worked in nursing homes for the last uh
so it looks like you have a presentation
and uh so the way the way we can do this
she didn't see the morning stuff did you
yeah because she have real jobs I
understand so
um so we're I'm gonna just let you go
through this and before you flip to the
next page uh you may want to just look
up in case I want to get your attention
and uh and we'll you know anyone might
have a question
um so perfect all right none of them are
particularly hard I I think I think my
my frame of mind going into this is that
um the Hampstead Hospital is a strategic
asset and are taking care of kids youth
for the mental health and Behavioral
Health Sciences and uh it is a site that
often gets talked about as a potential
site to co-locate the new sununu center
the replacement Center for sununu and
the reason it might get cited along with
your
property is uh so the theory is through
co-location that we may be able to
leverage
staff
other capabilities like maybe you have a
logistics Warehouse sort of thing or you
know the ability to help out each other
for weekend meals so we're not always
Staffing kitchens all the time
nursing support in case somebody gets
hurt at 2 A.M you know how do we get
them emergency care that kind of stuff
is why we put co-location in and so as
you're going through this I'm I'm going
to be listening to to understand what
what your what Your Capacity is now what
you're doing now you know why you're not
doing more because you're probably built
to do more but you don't have a staff to
do more and and what all of that that
physical capacity and and Manpower
capacity what kind of implications that
may have for benefiting the co-location
of a replacement Center for sununu
that's my frame of mind we have new
people in the committee that have no
idea what a Hampstead Hospital is so we
could you know whatever you tell us is
going to be great news thank you
excellent I love it I love talking about
Hampstead Hospital so
all right fantastic so what I did do is
I included a photo of the actual
Hampstead Hospital
I'm not sure that any of you have ever
actually been to the campus but it is
beautiful it's been built on it was
built in 1974 on 100 Acre plus
um
site so it's beautiful grounds
um surrounded by trees and just wanted
you to have a visual to go along with
that
I'm sorry one of the things that I
wanted to make sure that I explained is
that
um in case you're not aware that
Hampstead Hospital
when the state took ownership of
Hampstead Hospital they subcont or
contracted with a third party vendor
well path Recovery Solutions for them to
provide the Clinical Services and
operate the hospital there and Sean will
get into this a little bit later on but
there is DHHS oversight we oversee the
entire contract and oversee the facility
at all times through our positions but
we do partner with well path Recovery
Solutions
so with our group we our executive team
we had gone back to the drawing board to
really come up with our new mission and
vision of what Hampstead Hospital is
looking to do and where we want to be
moving forward and our mission statement
as you can see is really to provide
trauma-inform patient and family
centered mental health treatment and in
accepting and supporting and supportive
environment
and then our vision
is for us to be able to be the center of
excellence for mental health treatment
of children adolescents and young adults
so I'm I'm an old broken down Army
Lieutenant Colonel uh that worked in
healthcare services and and so I've been
in and around mental health providers
for you know 40 50 years this phrase
trauma-informed I think started to enter
the Lexicon in the last decade I think
uh what what does this term really do I
mean why why isn't this just embedded in
what we do in a mental health
environment why is it why has it become
necessary to make sure everything is
said
um
that we take a look at the practices and
so trauma-informed Care Now brings with
it there are a lot of evidence-based
practices that come along with that and
there's also a movement to really help
and in to alleviate mental health stigma
um within society and be able to
understand for people to understand that
um
everyone has been witness to trauma in
their lives and then that the impact
that that has at the different levels
and stages of growth and development and
how you can treat them
thank you
absolutely
any other questions on that one before I
move forward all right
the next page is just a listing of our
executive team and as you can see I did
want to break down for you so there is
the team of DHHS leaders and also our
well path Recovery Solution
uh as far as so these these five DHHS
employees that this this is really it
other than the u5 everything else is
so moving forward
um into the overview for hhrtf
um the state took ownership June 8th of
2022.
um we were really focusing at that point
on being able to increase the efforts
post-pandemic uh for recruiting and
retention so that we were able to
increase the bed capacity
um for Hampstead
the average census since June 8th has
been approximately 36 patients and we're
continuing to increase
those numbers through Recruitment and
Retention strategies
the average weightless since June 8 was
13 patients
waiting for beds at our facility
we've seen since being State involved
that we've had an increased
collaboration with dcyf division for
Youth and children
and then also with the division for
Behavioral Health we've been able to
actually
incorporate weekly meetings so that
we're able to really take a look at each
individual child and what their needs
are and where we can best treat and
serve them throughout our system of care
in New Hampshire
um that was a welcome change
um for me to be able to be part of that
so that we can we can do that work
um just a little information our patient
and family satisfaction surveys our
results have been
um 90 of satisfaction
and then our annual average readmission
rates remain
approximately at four percent for those
rapid readmissions which are within 30
sure so I have some questions about go
go ahead
thank you very much
um I just have a question on the um the
range of the ages does a youth age out
at 18 and and how young are the children
you're servicing absolutely and I will I
should have ordered this a little bit
differently maybe
um I will get into that too but we take
ages four
um up through 17 as a designated
receiving facility and then we also care
for patients 18 to 25.
I represent Waller
thank you
um can you tell me what is the average
weight
so the average I don't have that with me
currently
um what it was last quarter so the end
of quarter four was an average of seven
days waiting
um for our our highest triage level
you're welcome
um so I think I have three questions or
simple one so
um the cat form and uh I I keep
forgetting what the acronym is but it's
a it's a clinical assessment treatment
plan or something like that uh is is
that is that integrated into our health
care System enough so that when these
kids arrive at your facility a huge
percentage of them has a cat already
available or are you having to create
them
we typically are not the ones that are
generating those if they do come in to
our facility and they've already been
connected or they to a Community Mental
Health Center or throughout the system
they have already had that referral
there are times that they may come to
the facility and they haven't actually
had the assessment completed and it will
get completed while it's there but the
process has been started already okay
because that's a big theory about how
we're trying to take care of kids right
we're trying to get these early
assessments and have the assessment move
longitudinally with the child and and
and hopefully have less discontinuity of
care and and better results as a result
absolutely okay so
um you mentioned
um your your head counts your census uh
what what what's your vacancy rate
generally on your clinical side the part
that's affecting your your bed capacity
um currently right now we are um staff
ratio or sorry our vacancy rates are 52
for direct care counselors and 39 for
nurses
those are vacancy rates right correct
okay
oh my God
so so let's say you had both of those
components above 90 what what would that
do to your bed capacity would you
instead of being at 36 would you you'd
be at a much higher number but what
where do you think you'd be yeah
absolutely
um and you'll see again the order of my
way we're still excited about this
yeah
put it all in one slide okay next time I
will I'll remind you you asked for that
um so the the um currently today our
census is actually 45. this is just what
our averages are
um so our current census is 45 uh and we
actually have 20
um staff that we just hired that are in
orientation coming out of orientation of
and of those people there are 11 of them
are direct care so we will be able to
stay within that 40 to 45 range and in
addition to that we've also have
um
anticipated 14 more employees 13 of
which are direct care that are supposed
to be starting on February 6th so we've
definitely seen a a huge shift in
applicants and folks that are coming on
board to to take care of the patients
which is great so how many of your
residents are there on a non-voluntary
basis
currently I'm happy to say they're all
voluntary okay voluntary by Guardian
by so the guardian has asked for the the
child to receive the residential
treatment correct no court orders not
right now could could you receive a
court order yes and you have in the past
yes we have in the past
um that's something that we're very
proud of is
um that our social workers and our
clinical team really work well with the
families to help to integrate them so it
really comes down to
um truly only those children and
adolescents that don't meet
um that their families really are
opposed to them receiving any type of
psychiatric treatment that end up on a
true involuntary admission so so you all
were in the news in the last week or so
because uh one of the patients left the
left the grounds
and I think that caused a lot of
confusion and concern about the sununu
center being co-located so I just want
to I just kind of want to make it clear
my understanding is that the Hampstead
Hospital is not intended or designed to
be a secure facility there's no sort of
uh
well there's probably some little bit of
lockdown between between Wards
um could you could you talk about sort
of the security posture uh I've heard
things like uh sununu's a level five we
don't have any other facilities or level
five we have level fours and level
threes what what help us understand the
level of security that you have there
yeah absolutely can we switch to them is
there actually another slide that oh all
right okay very good oh oh you know but
did you tell me what your maximum bed
capacity would be if you had all your
it's in there oh God you are so good
I was anticipating your needs yeah thank
you
um so I just wanted to to break down and
this I think may help and then we can
get back to some of those other
questions
um that our current we have four
inpatient locked psychiatric units that
are capable of serving 70 patients total
currently we have three of those that
are operational due to Staffing
Resources
the total bed capacity on the three
units is 55 patients and that is
Staffing dependent if as long as we can
have enough staff to safely manage the
patients
um and then the current census today is
45 and actually our current wait list is
um patients today
um so and of those I will I just want to
point out that the the biggest barrier
for for those to get in is really the
need for single bedrooms
um so there are eight patients on our
wait list that are requiring single
rooms and so we have to wait for
patients to leave from those single
rooms for those other patients to come
in so how do you segregate the genders
is it by uh Ward or is it by room
it's by room yep so on each unit and
we'll get into that on the next page
um so in addition to those inpatient
units we also have one residential level
Care Unit
um that will be the site of the level
five psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility
and that those Renovations are going to
be beginning very soon
on the next page is where I break it all
down for you yeah so we have our Madison
unit that's a 15 bed unit it's currently
vacant and it's vacant
um we're waiting for Behavioral Health
Furniture to be installed on that unit
that unit was an adult unit and we only
ever took voluntary adults so the
environment needed to be made more
secure and safe for the Child and
Adolescent population different
furniture that can't be thrown things
like that
um so that that unit is currently vacant
and then we're also need we would need
to increase and recruit more staff to be
able to stand that unit back up
uh the Lincoln unit that is our 23 bed
Child and Adolescent unit and the ages
on that unit are approximately 12 to 18.
on the Pierce unit we can we have 16
beds and that's ages 4 to 14.
and then on the Washington unit we have
that's our 16 bed unit and that is our
young adult unit right now and that's
ages 16 to 25.
so maybe maybe I'm not uh
typical but I I have a hard time
imagining why a four or five-year-old
would be in a residential facility can
you can you kind of tell us a little bit
about the clinical presentation of a kid
that that young that was yeah absolutely
breaks our heart every time
um but they are typically
um patients that have
suffered severe trauma
um have you know have been severely
abused
um also parents are typically don't have
the skills to be able to handle their
behaviors that are a result of that
trauma and abuse
and in addition that young typically
we're seeing that they may be
cognitively delayed as well and maybe on
the autism spectrum in addition to their
other behaviors or they may have some
intellectual disabilities that require
them to be under under
current watch to be able to be trialled
on medications and behavior techniques
we have on that unit we have Behavior
analysts that particularly focus on that
unit for those younger kids that really
can work to develop a Behavior Support
plan and determining the function of
each of the behaviors
so so this is horrible that's a horrible
thing but um so um
they're physical
physiological status is it uh driven
also because of maternal drug use are we
talking about permanently impaired
children and that we need to train to
cope with their feelings sometimes
we we you know it it varies
um each presentation is is unique but
that does happen more often than we
would like to see it happen and you've
got typical patient presentations I'm
not seeing I see intent to harm but do
you have the patients that have actually
harmed and and are somewhat of a public
safety risk
we do yeah and that that's really these
are the typical presentations of why
they get through the door and if you
think about
um
the state of New of insurance these days
you have to present a significant
imminent risk of harm to yourself or
others to be able to be approved for
hospitalization so they're typically
these patients will be assaultive and
aggressive in school in the community to
their families in addition because
that's how they've learned to cope and
and to get their needs met I I get that
um so I I'm flipping through trying to
anticipate my questions but or your
answers but um but so I'm still looking
for this uh security level designator
and I don't see that in here so we do
our they're all all of our units our
inpatient units are locked they are
locked units the patients all when they
are admitted to the hospital they are
have no restriction no
no
um
what is the word
just went out of my head it's on the
next slide it's it's not uh
privileges thank you so they have no
privileges so they're restricted to the
unit
um until they are D met with their their
treaters and decided that they can be
off the unit with staff our patients are
always with staff in that situation
where we were the patient eloped they
were actually out on the swing set being
able because they had shown safe
behaviors and then impulsively decided
to to run so there is Security in place
with locks and then patients are with
staff but it is not there's no fencing
there's no security around that we do
have
safety ambassadors that is our new
roles that we have brought in since the
state has come taken ownership and the
safety Ambassador
staff they actually are what in normal
facilities would be for referred to as
security
but we really were not focusing on
security and really wanting to focus on
how it is that we can
provide support for our staff have that
additional support and resources but
still being trauma informed and people
being understanding of the way that you
have to approach a psychiatric patient
so the actual metric for rating this
secure level
sununu is a five do you you don't know
what your number is I think you probably
have a number somewhere so within our
system within the system of Care sununu
Center is a completely different and I
can't really speak to that but within
the system of care the residential
levels level five is the highest level
for psychiatric
for residential but we are one step
above that that so in essence there
isn't a level for it but inpatient
psychiatric care if you wanted to give
it a number would be a six hmm
I misunderstood so you just taught me
something I thought five was the highest
from a just a security perspective and
that the lower ones we may be speaking
different yeah in different terms yeah
all right
um so I've asked a lot of questions are
there any questions from the committee
at this point any questions
all right uh I I think I've asked all my
questions so you now get to run wild
okay
the next uh slide actually goes into a
little bit of detail about what our prtf
the psychiatric residential treatment
facility is going to look like that is
on our Kennedy unit uh it will be a
level five treatment facility one level
below inpatient
um it will be Children and adolescents
and young adults ages 5 to 21 per CMS
regulations that will be the um the
age range that will be served served
there it is a 12 bed capacity it's
family driven youth guided
multi-disciplinary train teams and then
multiple treatment modalities will be
put in place for their these children
are there longer term so they actually
will attend a full day of school that
will be provided as opposed to on our
inpatient we provide tutorial services
for patients that are there longer than
two weeks
um so I lied because it's level five
just triggered me
uh I know that the commissioner
commissioner shemene before she left one
of her last things that she was trying
to figure out was the worst case
scenario if they had to close the sununu
center well where would they uh outplace
those uh those kids and I'm seeing that
you have a level five treatment facility
here I'm I'm wondering the extent to
which in the worst case scenario you
could or could not or shouldn't or
should not
receive kids from sununu and to the
Kennedy unit or another unit
uh
we we do take patients
um from that are in acute psychiatric
need the perimeters around what
qualifies for a psychiatric Residential
Treatment level of care level five is
different than a security
potential level five so through the cat
assessment that's where their level of
need gets determined so that if they do
have a need for a level five placement
they could be referred to to our
facility for for that level of care
okay so then the next half of that
question was to the extent that you had
an opportunity to Think Through It
is the Kennedy unit potentially a place
where if we had to we could outplace
sununu residents
I I don't really have that information
to be able to I I wouldn't know their
presentations so I don't know because
it's really around meeting the criteria
for the psychiatric residential level
that's why it's trauma informed and not
physical security informed right
okay
questions I think you're good okay
all right
and then the next slide uh just really
gives you just a breakdown of the
services that we offer at Hampstead and
what it is that that we do
I don't really know that you need me to
go through all of these things
um it really is just to give you a
little bit of insight in case you're
wondering hey can we handle some of
those kids that may not meet these
criteria but this this is really the
outline of the types of services that we
do we do psychiatric assessment and
medication evaluation inpatient teach
them coping skills to help to develop
safety plans and then get them back into
their Community because that really is
our number one goal is to be able to get
them back with their families or back in
a community setting where they can go
back to having somewhat normal lives
so tell me about the continuity care
when they leave your facility how do you
help make sure that there's or or to or
or or at least aware of the extent to
which they're successfully trans
transitioning back into their Community
yeah we have a stellar social work
department that actually does an amazing
job with setting up Aftercare that's the
Aftercare Begins the day that the
patient is admitted they will begin
planning for that discharge with
figuring out what they already have for
services in place what's needed if there
are gaps in services
again we go back to those weekly
meetings that they participate in to be
able to actually talk about the needs of
individual patients if we have a home a
child that's in a homeless situation you
know will involve different departments
to say Hey you know we have this child
he's going to go back out into the
community with his family that's
homeless what can we do what things can
we put in place
so they set all of that up prior to
discharge and when the patient is ready
for discharge that's all reviewed with
the families and every patient that
leaves our facility is set up with
Aftercare appointments with their first
appointment set for their their needs
foreign
do you do you leverage any uh
telemedicine or Telehealth to establish
a connection between the patient and and
back into the community prior to
discharge do you have any tell
telemedicine capability as part of your
no we don't okay
all right
okay thank you
question
thank you
um I know in in some adult care settings
you can have a program that's like a day
program is that a model that has ever
been used for youth or is that not seen
as a good I just think of it as a way to
have them with their family but still
receiving that full day of treatment
and it is and you just caught me I did
not prepare that piece because we
actually do have stepped down
um partial hospitalization for our
patients that are leaving inpatient we
have the ability to step them down to
partial if it's appropriate for them and
we do utilize it quite often we also
will accept previously admitted patients
into our partial hospitalization program
because we already will know them and if
they don't necessarily need that
overnight care and they have supports at
home we can do that
um in addition so I will make sure to
add that the next time into my slides
the question representative thank you Mr
chairman I don't think you've covered
this yet but what is the the average
duration of a stay for your patients and
could that further be broken down by age
for example um you gave a breakdown of 4
to 17 18 to 25 year olds is there an
average for the age range on how long
they stay Thank you absolutely so our
average length of stay for the
the younger patients because it tends to
be a little bit more complicated and
then also with really doing a lot more
around the family
um training and things like that their
average length of stay typically is
around 10 to 14 days
and then on our young adult unit the
average length of stay is typically also
it's it's closer to that seven to eight
day range
what I will tell you is that we do have
longer lengths of stay
awaiting placement things like of that
nature but we also have shorter lengths
of stay so those really are around the
averages
so I'm I I think I'm um
stereotyping a typical model of having a
parent or a guardian at home and and
some sort of family support environment
to help discharge the patient back into
but I'd like to make sure I understand
the worst case scenarios around all of
that you know there are probably some
kids that really ought not to go back
into their home setting uh for multiple
reasons or they just don't have a
competent a potentially competent adult
support network What What In Those edge
cases where there isn't a stable home
what what do what do we find ourselves
needing to do to make sure that we don't
put a kid back into a bad situation or a
situation that's just not going to be
productive oh absolutely and again that
happens more often than we we like to
see it as well
um but in those situations it really is
um a great collaborative effort between
dcyf Children's Bureau
where we're trying to figure out and
that cat assessment again comes back
into play to determine do they need
residential level of care do they need
Therapeutic Foster home what is it
really that that they need
and then we attempt to get that for them
so we have critical shortages in
Therapeutic Foster Homes right we don't
have people ready to fill that whole
need so so if that's what they need then
what are we doing we're continuing to to
work with in the system to try to find
the least restrictive environment for
these children on a day-to-day basis we
currently have nine children that are
awaiting placement that have been with
us a significant amount of time we will
never send our patients
um out in you know back into a difficult
situation if they if they really need to
be somewhere safe and secure
so when they're in that kind of holding
waiting status are they still considered
to go against your average wait time or
your average uh length of care time or
are they in a different status they're
they're in a different category
okay and you just said you had nine of
those and and those can take
months potentially right
okay so so so how often do you have a
child that there's just nowhere for them
to go home
that we don't have a Therapeutic Foster
Care for that we're still needing to
manage inside your facility
[Music]
um
on the regular we have that at least you
know on a weekly basis where there are
our children that are still waiting for
for other other placements that are are
stable and with us yeah so so you're
really serving a very vital safety net
feature you're not you're not just part
of the the workflow the clinical flow
you're also a significant safety net to
make sure that those that are not
flowing through our system still have
provision of care
correct I don't think I see that slide
though sorry
but okay we're hoping to fix that part
of the system right well you know I I
was I sat in on the Hampstead uh
briefings last year but it was just so
um kind of the whole thing was so
overwhelming I never really got a deep
feel for what you guys see so I really
appreciate what you're what you're
sharing with us today
um so are there questions for
I don't have that number with me I'm
sorry I know
um
I I really I don't I don't want to give
you an incorrect number but I could
certainly get that back to you I'd be
interested to see how many children are
actually going through that so that's
contacts you're looking for total and
unique contacts yes the total number of
children that they actually feels like
it's easily over 250 but I'd be
interested in that number
yeah absolutely I mean I know our our
patient days are are well over you know
a thousand per per month so
great thank you yeah I will get that
back to you representative Northern
children that go home and then end up
coming back for various reasons yep our
annualized readmission rate is
um four percent our readmission rates
this past month was two percent okay
I don't see any other questions you can
continue if you'd like excellent so as
you move forward you can see our slides
that include our average Staffing filled
rates versus vacancy rates
um these these are our filled rates
um so you can see that we've had a
pretty volatile time but what this shows
is really there was the um the state
assisted Hampstead Hospital even before
by trying to get the children out of the
the uh emergency departments and into
our beds they assisted with the maximum
contract for the strike force team and
that was went through July
um and into August so then we start to
improve and you can see through we were
using a lot of agency Staffing as well
as folks that were that well path
Recovery Solutions Had cover
um from other areas during this time and
then once we hit the holiday period and
time we saw a lot of turnover with folks
that didn't want to work on holidays and
we're we're leaving and now the
workforce we were not seeing very many
applicants at that point
as you can see in January things have
improved and increased
and we are now
at that level where where I explained
where we're going to be able to keep
those numbers up
significantly and we are feeling pretty
confident in our ability to continue to
increase that overtime so what happened
why why are I I I see the data yeah but
what's what's underlying the data what
happened
applicants
they they're applicants
um and now the holiday season has passed
and people are back out looking for the
workforce we typically will see that we
don't have a whole lot of applicants
around the holiday time people don't
want to start a new job and then people
leave because they don't want to work
the holidays
um and then we start to see the
beginning of the year folks will again
be looking for work
oh so we just need to saddle everyone
with a Christmas bill and we can fix our
stacking problem wouldn't that be nice
uh representative Waller
so when I'm looking at this chart
I see that you had a really big drop off
a nurse your counselors seem to stay
about the same
but the nurses really have dropped
really dropped off and you're trying to
build back up but it's still much lower
than you have had
are you feeling competition for the
nurses with the hospitals and other
health care facilities that are
providing bonuses and retention
incentives yes and that's something that
we also have been looking at with well
path Recovery Solutions
we meet bi-weekly to actually discuss
those those Innovations and really
trying to increase those we we are
offering bonuses to try to attract
people and as we instituted that you'll
see that that's really kind of where we
started to be able to see some of the
increase in those as well thank you
what about how to fill in their Staffing
that that's exactly why you can see in
October we had such a a high number of
nurses is we were really using those
agency nurses and I know Sean will be
speaking more to that because it's very
very expensive
and so really looking at that and it's
it's nice I don't want to steal your
thunder Sean but it's it's nice that
these numbers here are representative of
nurses that we have been able to
actually hire on now and we do we have
our last agency nurses that are going to
all right okay okay
the next slide is just an X by a picture
of what our admissions and discharge
averages are over the different months
and what you'll see here is when we took
uh the state took over in June
we had more discharges than admissions
really what we wanted to be able to see
is what we're starting to be able to see
in January now with the admissions
outweighing the discharges we wanted to
be able to increase and increase those
bed capacities and we also wanted to be
sure that we were at least admitting at
the same rate as discharging patients as
well
okay I'd like I'd like to tell you the
story that I have in my head about
Hampstead and then you could I'm asking
you to correct it
um that Hamstead before the state
acquired it was an ongoing viable
concern they they had their patient mix
and the revenues and the expenses they
were they were essentially uh at least
in a break even if it not a profitable
situation and then the the state has
come in uh and and we're basically
adding some capacity with some State
money and but but but I but I think the
principle was that we were going to
continue to try to run Hampstead
predominantly like
um
and so it had a for-profit component
then you know certainly at least you
know pay pay your way and and that so
far
um you all seem like you're in a good
position to do that as I'm looking at
the the admissions and discharges and
the and the shortage of the census I'm
I'm just I'm just wondering what you can
tell us publicly about
um the Financial Health of Hampstead and
the ongoing viability of the business
model as you understand it and and
please correct me on the business model
because that was not accurate
that no um that is is exactly Hampstead
was Hampstead Outlook Hampstead Hospital
as it was before was a for-profit
um and that that was true we were barely
Break Even but that was you know in
relation to all kinds of varying effects
now that the state has taken over
I'm gonna let Sean the CFO have this
conversation because we've managed to go
right to his section now and he can fill
so yeah just in regards to to that
question in particular
um I think now with census being low we
also have had lower Staffing levels so
it is more or less aligned to you know
our vacancies our meeting what our
census can can facilitate so
um we are currently in a
um
an okay position financially but again
with the new hires coming on we're going
to have added expenses to which we're
going to be building census uh forward
and building it up in addition to the
prtf coming on so we should be in a in a
better spot
um as time goes on
um but the
um our revenues and expenses yeah
they're they're pretty
um
our expenses are are matching more or
less what our census is at and our
so so if that was all running you know
perfectly and that described 100 of the
operations yeah the theory is you
wouldn't need any augmentation of
General funds
and and I and so I'm just looking to
validate if that's a a bad way of me
viewing it or inaccurate So currently
right now we have
um arpa funds that are funding Us in
addition to our Medicaid dish funds
um and then our agency income so the
arpa funds will not be available in the
coming years
um which will create uh discrepancy or a
hole in the budget to where General
funds may be needed right and I I had
promised Mr White that we weren't going
to talk numbers so so far I'm just
talking subjective Theory descriptive
stuff and not numbers but I'm just
trying to get a my mindset on on the
extent to which there may be a hole that
General funds are going to need to fill
did you want to say something Mr White
I I I'm just looking for just a little
context here on on where we're going
with state requirements yeah sure so um
you you'll see as Sean alluded to
already in our agency budget we did
include a certain assumed uh patient
Revenue amount and other funds um as
well as a nine million dollar general
fund prioritized need in our efficiency
budget
one of the reasons that we did that is
that we don't really have a good history
for what the patient revenues and what
the what what the Staffing expenses will
be as we continue to ramp up so we
intentionally try to incorporate a
buffer there to address that scenario
because we do have a different operating
model than Hampstead Outlook Inc did and
and because of that we can't necessarily
look back and say well these were their
expenses these were their revenues let's
base our new projections on that because
we've we've we're the state we're
different
um and and we also have this this public
partner private uh excuse me this
public-private partnership with with
wellpath to help facilitate and and be
part of the executive team
um and and facilitate the daily
operations there so at this point in
time Sean and I have had conversations
about this about trying to
as we enter the house and the Senate
phase have more accurate projections for
what that real need will be in the long
run
so okay so I'm just to stay out of the
conceptual level you use the term buffer
okay the way I think of a buffer is that
you're going through a transition you're
getting new data you're getting new
ideas about what the operating model is
going to do and because of that
transition and the uncertainty
associated with it you would have a
financial pad that could buffer the
uncertainty of that which is a distinct
thing and this is kind of where I'm
really going is is do we think yet that
we're going to have an ongoing
wedge that the state will always need to
put in to supplement the ongoing
operations of Hampstead or do we think
once we get through this transition
there they they will be able to be
self-sustaining I don't know if we have
the data yet to really make an informed
decision on that I mean I can certainly
I mean I think every I think I know what
everyone's goal is I mean I think we
would all love it for to be self-funding
but I are excuse me self-funded but
um I I don't yet think we necessarily
have the ability to answer that question
in the long run because you know we we
acquired the facility on June 8th and
there's often a two to three month lag
in receiving those patient revenues so
even though it's you know three months
it can be longer right yes
um no comment
um but but we we're not really there
from a from a history perspective of
really having what I would be all right
I don't want to put you in a corner I
just I I it's just a strategic question
with Hampstead and I'm just looking for
one we think we may have an answer
that's all so you have a question
representative Waller you do I I was
wondering how many arpa funds did you
receive
oh
a little more than nine million dollars
over what period of time
so as a simple math there that there was
9 million there's not nine million so we
need to come up with nine million or
okay thank you anyone else
this was one of your special areas that
you wanted us to talk about
representative nordgren are you
satisfied
all right thank you all right
uh do you have more you have a wrap up
you have a finale I bet
I'm gonna hand it over to me although I
I wish I wish I started because I don't
think I could be as eloquent or explain
as well as Kathy's done so I apologize
in advance so you know it's great it's a
good looking suit that's what I was
uh so I'm just going to speak a little
bit about the the budget and then sort
of our organization structure and the
field questions as we go all right um so
um
much to your previous question we had um
we have 27 State Physicians right now
um so six of those are unclassified
positions
um and those consist of the DHHS
executive team and contracts manager and
then we have 21 classified physicians in
our finance department our health
information Department facilities
um and then our our biggest chunk of our
budget is our our well path contract
which consists of 185 positions and that
will cover Administration business and
HR Support maintenance clinical health
care and program services
any questions on that so so you'll find
if you come back that I have a pet rock
with uh it and and you were
self-sufficient in I.T prior to the
state moving in and now you have a
department of I.T that is supposed to be
worried about uh core infrastructure
that's common and and Security Services
to what extent are the I.T departments
at this point integrated or is that
still a major work in progress It's a
work in progress so we're still in the
the wiring phase of putting uh the
cabling through the the building we do
have I mean access to State Employees
have access to all the systems and
things that they need to perform their
job while path has access to all their
system but the integration is still a
work in progress and and I would assume
during that work in progress that
there's absolutely no concern additional
or incremental concern of about security
or privacy of the data
that that part of that those issues are
stable and it's and and they're okay
yeah
we're a paper facility oh no
we gotta make you more vulnerable and
oh my God
all your fax machines and everything or
this is
the wrong time the wrong day to be
asking this but it goes down in 24 and
25 by almost that magic 9 million
dollars
have you are you renegotiating a
contract with
so those were the startup costs
associated with
um with the well path uh partnership
okay so they anticipated it was around a
10 million dollar cost okay I think they
will have them for the next two years
I think that covers your remarks you're
prepared to make today
did you are you all done are you guys
yeah I can I can wrap it up I I think
Miss Tilly has some place to go we
should give her a chance totally fine
with me so so I gotta tell you the the
most fascinating thing I heard is that
you're still in the paper world I don't
know how you survived right because
every payer is pushing you to go
electronic like a decade ago so so what
happened what what what what what
created sort of this uh you know this
vacuum of where you guys can still be
paper-based and you don't have an I.T
system
it was Finance driven when we were
Hampstead Outlook and we do have that is
part of our our budgeting processes we
actually will be moving to an electronic
world so your your financial stuff is
digital and electronic but the the
clinical record keeping is not yet
yeah exactly some somewhat on the
finance side okay well good I just make
a great project for a few people yeah so
all right uh thank you are there any
other questions for the committee all
Miss Tilly I think you know you're next
it said 1 30 or 2. I think I think we
well thank you so much for having me for
the record my name is Patricia Tilley I
am the director of Public Health most
people call me Tricia or Trish it is my
I am pleased to be here today to present
some information about the impact and
planning for the expiration of 19 funds
I'm only going to talk about covid
related items only time we'll have time
later in the budgeting process to hear
about the full range of activities that
we do in public health but of course I'm
always happy to answer any questions
that you have this presentation is
really a look back and a look forward
public health will participate in all of
the department-wide efforts in terms of
strategic planning but what I plan to
share today are the areas in which we
know we'll need more attention and
resources as we move forward I'm going
to talk about covid-19 investments in
our laboratory disease investigation
immunization data modernization and
public health informatics Community
Investments and public health Workforce
in response to representative Edwards
earlier question around statutory
Authority
I have highlighted on the slides some
areas the specific rsas that enable our
work I also have a separate summary so I
don't know Kevin if you would like this
now or when we come back in for the
budget
here separate summary
um I I gathered all of our statutes just
at a very high level for everything we
do across the division of Public Health
Services as you can imagine we've it's
it's a stack
um so I have that available if you want
to look at that now you can look at that
later or never all of those would be
good
so
um let's Jump Right In because I know
that all of you have been here and it's
been a long day so on slide two
um this is just sort of the super high
overview of of Public Health in general
and and you heard from the commissioner
that we just have an extraordinary
breadth of responsibilities in the
department each division Public Health
Hampstead Medicaid each also has their
own business model public health is
primarily funded by federal and other
funds to meet our broad mission of
protecting promoting and improving the
health of everyone in the state of New
Hampshire again we talked about this a
little bit earlier in some of the other
hearings that New Hampshire that public
health really is population based we
don't have a set of clientele like
Hampstead does our job is really to look
out for everybody
um so are federal funds come through
more than 50 separate uh federal grants
it's a lot to manage and we and some of
these funds are very temporary in nature
especially with regard to covid-19
they're meant to be an influx and then
they're going to go away
so when you look at the covid era 400
plus staff that's a different number
than what you saw
um Nathan present before a significant
number of those positions are temporary
positions they're what we call nine T's
eight T's there's a lot of part-time
positions in there as as Nathan
described we Flex these positions and
they are filled and demobilized and
filled and demobilized at frequent
intervals to meet the need that we have
we anticipate and are planning for
reductions in the workforce as we
transition out of covid
um I'll also note that in these 50 to 60
grants again across the entire book of
business in public health
um that's what makes me a frequent flyer
to come to fiscal all the time because
we're constantly adding money to the
budget outside of the state budgeting
process or
re-reallocating the money or asking for
a redirect because we're constantly
trying to make right the where the money
is going and where the needs are so
let's take a look at a pandemic
framework that we have and that's on
slide three so if we think about the
pandemic response that we have all lived
through you can think about it in three
rough stages there were the early days
in 2020 when we didn't have swabs to go
up people's noses to test individuals we
didn't have enough PPE anywhere we
didn't have masks to protect our front
line workers and then you know we
remember that we had to get the
deployment of the National Guard just to
even get a test I mean these are all the
things that we live through many of us
have tried to forget some of it but it
really is important when you think about
the amount of money that you're seeing
here
um you know and and right now we're at a
place where you can go get a covid
antigen test at CVS you know in the next
two minutes and and check yourself
um those early days
um required us to mitigate the spread
through active case investigation
contact tracing who remembers that it's
long gone
um and because we didn't have the tools
that we have now around vaccines or
life-saving therapy during that time we
experienced deaths of residents in
long-term care and facilities and other
chronic I mean in other congregate
settings and and also people just living
in the community many of us lost family
members in those early days we lost
Health Care Providers we've had over 20
Health Care Providers die in the state
and we lost leaders in our community
including some leadership even here in
the legislature
we focused on mitigation you look at
these air things that we got in here we
focused on mitigation efforts we focused
on social distancing policy makers like
yourselves debated whether and how
restaurants could open how we fly on
planes and many of us became overnight
experts on on air handling state and
federal resources dropped out of you
know the sky on us some of them were
extraordinarily helpful some of them
kept us afloat and and some were
probably less than helpful and I think
we've all learned a lot from that all
while we waited for those vaccines and
the Therapeutics to be available and
once those vaccines became available and
we were able to make some hard decisions
about who was first on the list who was
last on the list I mean you might
remember I I have social media it
reminds me of what I did on every day in
the past few years and I again it's
probably a little PTSD when I see some
of the things that happened in the past
three years but I think it's helpful
again for the context of the amount of
work that was put in over the past three
years so now here we are with
life-saving tools vaccines updated
boosters effective Therapeutics we have
most of what we need not everything but
we have most of everything to keep
people healthy most notably
Workforce and Technology being the thing
that's still in Need for us so you know
if we translate or skip to the next
slide we've gotten number four you know
why did we put all this money into covid
well because 3 000 people have died
can we check slide transitions sure okay
I am on slide four which is the so so I
have a couple of questions sure
um when it when you say uh and is is
that is Are We Now aiming at uh 11 May
the federal end date so that is the end
of the Federal Emergency covet isn't
going to magically disappear
but but this is kind of where we're
expecting where we're heading money and
federal guidelines and all that stuff so
you know a lot of those federal
guidelines will change most of them have
changed already we have not you know uh
after the State of Emergency the New
Hampshire states of emergency that
really had the most impact on public
health you know all of those that's long
gone
um our work won't fundam May 11th won't
fundamentally change what we do in
public it's just another day
the end of the story I'll give you you
know the end of the movie Fast you know
it's really uh we're gonna run out of
money in June uh 2024 in a lot of areas
we expect we'll get a one-year no-cost
extension to spend out what we didn't
spend in some of those funding sources
we're going to be at a real loss you
know a real dip in our resources in 26
and 27. so if you're planning this next
biennium we still have money
it's the biennium after that is going to
be that's going to require planning one
more question about that
um commissioner shivanay uh almost a
year ago talked to me in passing about
there being an after action review to
see if we could document the lessons
learned and she said that that she was
going to get Contract support for that
do you do you happen to know where we
are on whether or not we're really going
to do that so I think it's happening in
a multitude of ways so Homeland Security
is in the process of doing an after
action report right now and so that's
going to look at a lot of our response
including some of the public health
response as well so that's a very high
level after action we'll participate in
that that's ongoing
um I can tell you that in each of my
little areas and by little areas I mean
our laboratory our infectious disease
those areas we're doing those individual
after actions on our own right now and
really understanding in almost real time
what worked and what didn't work and and
will there be public-facing reports on
the Lessons Learned certainly the
Homeland Security emergency management
report will be very public and then
certainly anything that we do can be
made public as well okay are you are you
including right-wing conspiracy
theorists in order to make sure that we
get a lessons learned that covers a
broad range I think
I'll come to ask us questions anytime
and we're happy to provide any
information that's asked okay
thank you you're welcome so
it causes a death on that slide of note
coven was the third leading fourth
leading cause of death in 2020 so again
march to you know we coveted started in
March of 2020 between March and December
it was the fourth leading cause of death
that year because that was the year we
were all locked down by 2021 and we all
let we're out and about more people died
because we were out and about what we're
going to see in 2022 the final death
data is not finalized so I haven't
provided it for you because it takes a
long time to get death data from other
states of New Hampshire residents we are
likely to bump down to the fifth leading
cause of death in 2022 for New Hampshire
which is different than that at the
national number it looks like it's going
to stay third so we are different it may
be that we are different again those are
speculative they are preliminary numbers
at this point because we need to count
every death but it really does look that
we took a a step down in 2022 which is
great news that's exactly what we want
that's the reason we've spent all this
money money right so so in the old days
people would die of flu yeah uh is that
the is that the category chronic lower
respiratory disease no chronic lower uh
respiratory disease is really things
like emphysema COPD do we have flu on
here anymore flu is not in the top five
of leading causes of death we usually
have just around 200 230 deaths from flu
ently pre-pandemic during the pandemic
we know that number bottomed out to very
little because people just weren't out
and about this year given what's been
going around in the respiratory World
we're going to see the number probably
come back to what we used to see
pre-pandemic which was in the you know
low 200s again that's nothing like the
numbers we're seeing with covet
representative Mooney thank you Mr chair
thank you do you by chance have an age
breakdown for these lines for example uh
how many five to ten-year-olds and so on
so forth passed away from these
particularly coveted so um you can see
that right now if you wanted to Google
it on our New Hampshire kova dashboard
we have it broken down into age cohorts
you know 5 10 age five to ten years in
each age cohort and what the death rates
are so those are available right now
sure and we can certainly send that link
to make sure everyone has has it so but
I'm assuming in general what we'll
notice that the older you are with
comorbidities that was 80 90 of the
deaths yeah and and in a couple of
slides if you look actually you can
sneak up in a couple of slides I have
our dashboard page and you can see the
proportions or the numbers by age rank
so again 80 and older that was the group
that really had a hard time through
covid where we saw deaths you know when
we look at things like hospitalizations
though which um are incredibly costly
you know we see middle-aged we see
middle-aged people there the deaths we
really saw in older populations but
we've even had P you know we've had
pediatric deaths as well it's it's
occurred in you know for covid in every
age group but you know I agree with
representative Edwards the real group
that took up you know that was
disproportionately affected were older
adults thank you yeah great so we can
switch over to slide fives so let's talk
a little bit about the money that's a
slide that says dphs biennium budget so
more that you know what Nathan said not
to talk about money I'm going to give
you some very big high level numbers so
more than 77 million dollars have been
deployed to New Hampshire to address
covid-19 these are federal dollars this
changed our proportion of federal and
general fund mix to you know about seven
if you add all of that that means that
public health is an entirety is about 77
federally funded has about 17 percent
other funds and less than 10 percent
General funds to manage these funds
um you know we have developed a number
of covid-19 accounting units
um that we manage which is again things
that we see at the Joint legislative
fiscal committee all the time as we move
money in and out and redirect that money
we added 49 temporary State positions in
this biennium that we're currently in
not next by any but this current
biennium
um again I note that those are 98t
positions we've also used it Staffing um
contracts we heard Hampstead talk about
Maxim
um you know we were the first ones to
use Maxim
um in public health in those early days
of the pandemic you know at our height
we had over 250 Maxim staff or within
under those temporary contracts that was
when we were contact tracing and doing a
tremendous amount of work we have now
demobilized significantly and we're now
in the 40-ish range of of people working
on those temporary contracts I think the
the message that we would like to uh
relay throughout this presentation is
we've tried to be as Nimble as possible
and um really scale to the need that is
presented to us none of us wanted 250
temporary staff that was you know that
started to max out our ability even to
manage at that level
so we can move to the next slide so what
did this Federal funding enable us to do
what do the feds want us to do with the
money they wanted us to respond quickly
to all infectious diseases they wanted
us to prevent those outbreaks they
wanted us to do prevention and control
they also really understood that in
order to do this work to manage this
pandemic we needed investments in data
modernization Public Health
infrastructure informatics and
infrastructure communication capacity
Workforce capacity not only for those
nurses and contact tracers and
laboratory folks but across the board
all so that we could improve greater
outcomes not only the metrics of
hospitalizations and deaths you asked
earlier about what metrics we used at
the end of the day for covid I'm
watching hospitalizations and deaths
then we can break it down into a million
subparts but the number I'm watching
every day are hospitalizations and
deaths
um but the feds also wanted us to do
these broader things around in improving
things like healthcare quality and
Health Equity so I'm going to jump in
now unless there's a question into some
of the components of the response I want
to I want to talk about these two slides
interacting together the your biennium
budget slide with the 49 temporary
positions and and then the bullet slide
that follows
um okay so we received uh temporary
money to do temporary work
um and uh to what extent do you imagine
that temporary work actually going away
completely versus there will be some
Vestige appendage that we need to
continue to support that's that's the
million dollar question it's probably
more than a million dollars but it is a
million dollar question hoping you could
keep it to 900 000. I try to keep all my
accounting units to 900 000 because then
they don't come to your budget hearings
um
so you know I don't know the number
right now I mean that's really the magic
and I think we're going to know it over
the next two years but I can tell you I
know where we're going to need it we're
going to need money in informatics we're
going to need money probably a little
bit of money in our laboratory because
we're trying to right size this
laboratory and
um and we're going to need some money
and overall preparedness
um and then probably a decision that
will have to be made both at the federal
level of what they're going to fund and
if the you know the state general funds
want to wants to fund any of those
Community Investments things like
community health workers that's going to
be a question for this legislature and
and our federal Partners to decide is
that something that we want to continue
it's unlikely that the department is
going to come and ask for that money in
general funds but I think that those
policy decisions will probably be made
here okay but I I think I'm also hearing
that there's enough arpa money to get us
through the bulk of this budget that
we're about to prepare and even though
that you don't have the answer now or
soon we've got a couple of years to work
that's a huge relief thank you yeah we
have we're in good shape that way we
should have enough money of all of the
federal pennies that fell from heaven
to get us through the next two years
um it's really the next biennium that is
all right
um so let's go into the lab a little bit
so this is a on the lab slide it's
number seven
um that's a little screenshot from WMUR
when we had five cases of covid-19 and
it was newsworthy that we had five cases
of coven 19.
um we have put a tremendous amount of
money you heard earlier the acronym ELC
which is our epidemiology laboratory
capacity Cooperative agreement that's a
mouthful
um we've gotten lots of additional
Federal resources through that Federal
grant to support our laboratory services
our testing
um testing that occurs outside of our
laboratory so again remember when we
tested kids at school we tested kids at
summer camp that all came from federal
resources we don't do that anymore those
you know those funds have we don't we
don't need to use them schools are not
interested in that others are not
interested in that right now we've also
used this to support things like
Wastewater sampling we've bought some
equipment we've used this opportunity to
upgrade a lot of the equipment in our
laboratory we're always going to take a
moment to say if the money's coming you
know I will use it now so that because
we don't know that we'll have those
resources later on and of course we've
used it for Workforce
um in in the lab you know my just a
reminder to back in those days in 2021
we had two shifts of workers working
seven days a week in our laboratory and
infectious disease it was an
extraordinary effort I I'm not you know
other than our 24 7 facilities I don't
know where else we were working two
shifts seven days a week Department of
Transportation is probably the our other
folks who do that so that's our
laboratory fun fact for you on here
rsa131 it is the oldest piece of um
statute that we have on the books
related to Public Health the original
date on it was 1911. so that is when we
were put into statue to start work have
elaborate what was called the laboratory
of hygiene
all right no question huh we've been
we've been going since
um the next slide is around disease
investigation the you know this is
probably the most obvious to people
around what people think we've done with
our coveted money you know it is
um uh RSA again rsa141c gives us the
authority to investigate control and
prevent infectious diseases that's
that's pretty old on the books as well
not 1911 old but still pretty old
um you know at the end of the deck you
will see I've given you a list of all of
our reportable conditions the way it
works in New Hampshire is we have uh
statutory authority to collect
reportable
um communicable diseases in rule we
develop what those diseases are
certainly using um other resources like
CDC and others to help frame that on
that list you'll see everything from
chlamydia to E coli
um you don't see covid-19 though spelled
out that and people often ask about that
that coveted 19 was captured at the very
bottom of that list which is for novel
diseases of concern so as you will
remember that it was uh we were the
novel coronavirus that's how we started
talking about covet so it is captured
underneath that
um right now what we're doing you know
we're not doing contact tracing that has
gone away
um but what we've really settled into
the work and its ongoing work is helping
our congregate facilities with their
outbreaks so those are you know
outbreaks in nursing homes outbreaks at
the county jails outbreaks at the state
jail other settings where Healthcare
settings where we can help them and
provide some support on infection
control
um uh practices so I will move on then
so so I'm looking I'm looking at this
back page of years and I see where the
forms are uh URL
um but I'm sure the reporting is also
with all of those
of those do we do any flash Splash
reporting on like STDs I think you and I
first talked about that five years ago
that it would be helpful to get that
data into the hands of the people who
might be frightened by it uh are we
doing anything to so we are so an
interesting fact of covid-19 is all our
best disease investigators are are
veteran disease investigators were the
ones that were redeployed to covet so
now we're back putting those disease and
vectors A disease investigators and
really doing the epidemiology of STDs
again we've been continuing to collect
reports because it's required for the
healthcare agencies to tell us that and
so you know I'm laughing because my
staff know that almost every chance I
get I like to talk about STDs you know
I'll throw a gonorrhea in there whenever
I can
um so but we are seeing in all
seriousness we've seen an increase in in
conditions like gonorrhea which nobody
wants and not only are we seeing
increases but they are resistant to
antibiotics and so you I think you'll be
seeing more from us in a public way
around those issues we just issued
what's called a Han which is a a notice
to our health care providers around some
of those very concerning Trends yeah
okay so five years later I'm still
trying to figure out how we get that
information in the public Consciousness
in a way in which it's scary enough to
modify Behavior
all right all right
um so does that's that's our disease
investigation team we can flip into
immunization this is a hot button issue
I know lots of folks have lots of
thoughts and ideas around around vaccine
it was a place where we had a huge chunk
of this Federal money deployed to us we
you know we made available monitored and
administered over 2 million coveted 19
vaccines since late 2020. this is
extraordinary this is an extraordinary
lift no matter your thought on it it was
a lift to be able to get this done
um can you can you hold for
representative how
sorry thank you
um
yeah 2.6 million vaccines right and a
population of 1.3 we're now averaging
two per person or is that also including
ones that were not administered is that
no those are those administered so for
myself I've had four vaccines you know
I've had four administrations so you
know I think the adult population we the
numbers as we all know are not hard and
fast of exactly who got how many and we
in part that was because we did not have
an immunization information system up
and running in the beginning of this
system I can tell you for sure how many
vaccines were administered drawing it to
the exact person who got those shots
especially when someone like me has had
four it gets a little bit squirrely in
terms of the exactness of it but we can
tell you that adult that we that you
know close to 70 plus probably plus
percent of adults in New Hampshire
okay great
um so you know to steal a little Thunder
on that as well the other investment
that the federal money helped us do was
to create that immunization information
system
um not only is it the registry that we
have often heard talked about that's an
important part of it but really for me
what's even more important is the back
end which is where we might we manage
where those two million doses went how
they're monitored were they under the
right um temperature controls it's
really that back end that is also part
of the immunization information system
that is critical for us to have
appropriately Monitor and um make sure
that all the vaccine is getting where
it's supposed to and it's appropriate
and we can manage the safety side of
that as well
um we'll switch into data modernization
and public health infrastructure I think
representative Mooney has a question I'm
sorry I'm going to want to ask you about
our status on uh immunizing kids
go ahead
Mr chair and thank you very much uh with
regards to this immunization money
there's been a tremendous amount of
marketing for the vaccine and for
boosters and so forth either on Facebook
or social media or bulletin boards and
all this and that is there a general
breakdown for the marketing effort for
the covid vaccine and the follow-up
boosters with regards to federal and
state money sure or um I'm sure we can
get that for you it is a component the
communications piece and the marketing
was a required component in a lot of our
federal funds I can't say with certainty
but probably pretty close to certainty
that no General funds were used for that
that it really were all of the marketing
that we saw was really either State I
mean a federal funds CDC funds or there
were some arpa funds early in the
beginning when you saw some of those
early
um you know uh marketing with the
governor those those happened you know
outside of Public Health per se but
those likely used arpa funds to
um to make those commercials and things
like that representable
thank you um
looking forward or at least current is
it possible for your department to work
up where money is being spent in terms
of actual vaccines right marketing those
things as from this point forward as
opposed to how it was spent in the past
yes absolutely and we you know part of
the
the day is we're not sharing our entire
budgets but you know all of this money
has been accounted for mostly because it
is federal funds so I can tell you very
clearly where we have spent effort you
know whether it's Personnel or for a
marketing contract correct but I'm
thinking going forward right what where
is the plan and then can you also share
with us what flexibility you have so the
federal government throws some money
over to us and then they may have
strings attached to it more than likely
they have strings attached to it so we
don't see all of those contracts so if
you can tell us what flexibility you
have that would be great great and I
will suggest that uh um with all of the
federal funds that come they certainly
come before joint legislative fiscal
committee we've had lots of heated
conversation or you know Lively
conversation about some what's in the
back of some of those Cooperative
agreements what the strings were that
was certainly about a year and a half
ago that we had a lot of conversation
about that
um but you're correct one of the tricky
Parts about managing these more than x
number I mean 50 grants across all of
Public Health but you know of the 17
accounting units that are just covid is
that each one of them comes with a very
clear like set of bookends of what we
can and cannot do they are not flexible
block grant dollars they're not flexible
like arpa dollars
thank you
so about the kids
um I think you and I talked about this a
couple months ago so ago when we had the
the fiscal item to
um a couple million dollars or so to
help Target uh immunizations for kids
under 18
and at the time when we talked about it
you know listening to all the range of
constituents I was basically satisfied
with where DHHS was at the point of
saying we're going to use this money to
make it available but it's all it's
going to remain in the discretion of the
parent have you seen any movement in the
last two or three months for people to
try to mandate immunizations for kids in
this area thank you for that question
certainly not from the Department and it
is we've been very clear since the very
beginning we have no intention to
mandate covid-19 vaccine for school
entry or Child Care entry that it is
something that should be available
families can make that decision for
themselves based on their own risks and
their family circumstances we want to
make it easily available we don't want
to make it hard to access we want to
make it easy to access but it's the
parents ultimate decision for covid-19
vaccines for kids all right good answer
thank you
any other questions
okay great
um this is the lucky part of being the
last one okay you have uh all asked all
the questions you wanted so
um data modernization and public health
infrastructure to me this is this is the
thing that keeps me up at night this is
what we need to do as we move forward
and quite frankly when the money goes
away this is what we have to think about
how we sustain again in a biennium away
but it's my job to be thinking that that
extra biennium at the end of the day
um you know the pandemic created the
greatest need and the best opportunity
to modernize the way that we collect
data the way that we share data
um all that's within our statutory
Authority again through you know our our
statutes that are this is the I posted
on here RSA 126 that's our health
statistics
Authority but certainly through um RSA
141c which is the communicable disease
um so you know one of the things that
the that kova did is really
um the public demanded that we produce
complete accurate timely and accessible
and transparent information on a daily
basis there was no other time that we've
had that we were putting up real live
time numbers this was a huge lift for us
and I'm incredibly proud of the way that
the teams work together through these
Federal Investments to be able to show a
covid-19 daily dashboard I think it has
set the bar for the way that we share
data moving forward it was built on the
shoulders of something we call our New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services data portal it used to be
called wisdom if you were around then
um but in that case that was mostly
annual data and that was a hard enough
lift to constantly be updating annual
data and so that you could cut it and
move it and look at it by town now the
expectation is that more and more we
have that data in a much more timely way
than than annually so again this is I
look full project forward being able to
continue to support efforts like this
Beyond covid is really where where I
so when I first became aware of Public
Health as a field
it struck me that we're trying to manage
the health status of populations and
that and and then what's happened is we
have these emerging I.T Concepts around
data warehouses and data mining and uh
high-end analytics to start to get into
that data and really use it and I think
this slide that you have here on data
modernization Public Health
infrastructure you know it could it
could imply the the data warehousing and
data analytics but it doesn't make it
over that that's part of the strategy
and maybe Mr Wieters is going to come
talk to us about it but I could you just
tell me what you think about the
importance of data analytics built on a
data warehouses for the future what the
public health department does sure you
know I would always defer to Mr wheaters
to talk about the data warehouse or the
ebi as it's called behind it which is
EBR yeah and I am it's late in the
afternoon I'm blanking on that um
yes there you go thank you I I bailed
Nathan earlier intelligence
he is paying it forward
um
um but what I can tell you from the
analysis I mean it's it's all the you
know the way that I frame it's all the
squirrels in the back of the machine
like this is giving us the foundation of
the information that we have so that we
can use Vital Records where appropriate
where we can use population data in
order to do that deep dive of analysis
you know as I mentioned you can look at
our covid-19 dashboard right now and you
know the front page or if you even look
at slide 11 that's what you see when you
just click on it that gives you a you
know the quick overview of how many
people and that you know 80 plus year
olds have a higher number of of deaths
than any other age group or where in the
state there may be covid that is all
populated by some of that ebi as well as
the other inputs around things like
um in case of covid case reporting and
laboratory reporting that comes I want
to just jump down into the rabbit hole a
second okay uh the data analytics it
sounds to me like you think that you do
need a data analytics function and we do
have an analytics function right now
okay I'm sorry I said I I said we do
have a pretty robust data analytics okay
does that have to report in the public
health area or is that under the
informatics arm of Mr wheaters for
Public Health
public health statistics
Maddox and that is where a number of our
analyzes come from as well as within the
individual bureaus of things like
infectious disease as their own
analytics and epidemiology work maternal
and child health has their own you know
we have that spread throughout dphs we
can't do our work without that analysis
um
I'm sorry there's a question
representative Morgan thanks to comment
for your information
these aren't labeled with numbers I know
I'm sorry that's okay
because you were talking about page 11 I
was like oh
thank you representative for that
reminder I'll tell you what's on each
one so you know
did you have a question
you did
so I believe this was page 11 if I got
your pages correctly correct thank you
um so this is one of the several
dashboards that are on the
covet19nh.gov dashboard trackings page
correct
um who
and what group drove the data that's
published there and in particular I'm
looking at the what this is the Key
summary tab right as opposed to the
front page the landing page which you
just gave us there's information there
that seems right that's really important
to get out to people and I it's not
highlighted I'm just wondering
who were the key decision makers and
what ended up in that summary page
that's a great question thank you
representative
um I'm going to go in the way back
machine as we were trying to figure that
out two or three years ago
um it was it was a number of people that
came together it was a number of
requirements from our federal Partners
so we're required to report these things
federally to the CDC some of those
breakdowns there was an interest in
particular around Health disparities
among people with racial and ethnic
um considerations that actually moved
particularly in New Hampshire where we
are now
certainly um equally if not even more
concerned about rural populations versus
racial and ethnic we know that there are
age groups we in public health we look
at groups of people in all sorts of
different ways and so
um but we also had input from all levels
of leadership with both within the
department in the governor's office and
certainly uh early on the science
um was driven by you know our state
epidemiologist Dr Chan Dr Ballard and
others all contributed to where this um
where we got to with this particular
website lots of information we got a
team of epies
um we don't do ever anything by
ourselves in one person by themselves at
Public Health we takes a committee to do
anything great thank you
representative tolersky did you have a
says chart but that major major spike
over the winter of 21 to 22. yep I'm
curious if and this is something I've
wondered
um when as a community we transitioned
to self-testing and administration of
tests I always wondered about the data
and those numbers we see and are we just
you know discounting all of those
self-tests um how are you coming to that
and does that have
this Spike there does that have anything
to do with the transition to
self-testing and non-reporting sure so
thank you thank you for that question
um I'll I'll combat your answer in sort
of the back way so certainly since um
all of the home-based antigen tests made
available we knew we would never have an
accurate number of actual cases so what
is represented here and always has been
represented here were laboratory
confirmed or Health Care confirmed tests
so if you went to your doctor's office
that's who's reporting here hospitals
somewhere else that's what this this
um curve represents it's not it never
represented what you had
um you know with your CVS antigen test
so that's really when early on we were
focused on cases I mean you may even
remember the first slide we were very
excited in 2020 when we had five cases
um we made a shift in during this time
to really look at hospitalizations and
deaths as our marker of of disease and
concern rather than the number of cases
because what we've also seen and I think
folks you know you know this intuitively
from your own families as more immunity
came in the community there were uh less
uh bad outcomes or you know the outcomes
were better for larger groups of people
so we saw you know sort of
proportionately fewer hospitalizations
we still have plenty of hospitalizations
but we saw both immunity naturally and
with vaccine
you've been waiting for me to say it you
said it you set natural immunity
both of those things have impacted I
mean if we remember back at that time
that is when we had National Guard in
our hospitals so you know it's not like
we are still there we are not still
there because we no longer have the
National Guard in our hospitals you know
we see those those indicators so that's
why we use hospitalizations and deaths
right now because that's really what
we're concerned about
does that does that answer your question
yes
um I knew we had made that transition to
hospitalizations and death can you
remind me on the calendar when that was
as I look at this um I mean I think
we've always focused on hospitalization
and death so there wasn't a magic moment
but it really was at the end of last
year where we made you know where we saw
that giant Spike but it was at the same
time you'll you might recall we
um the governor had us uh use some arpa
funds to purchase antigen tests that
were available in liquor stores like we
were it was just at that time that
antigen tests could roll out to the
community and so now we certainly know
that most people likely are at least
testing the first time at home and then
may have a follow-up test at a
healthcare provider especially if
they're not well
I'm I'm looking through your your slide
deck and you got another report and then
you got how ECR works yeah we can flip
through all of that if you don't want to
hear any of that that's fine no no I I
just like alerting people that I I don't
I don't know that you need to say much
about those if people have questions
we'll take them I I and and I'm I'm
wondering if this one with the workforce
foundational capabilities and data
modernization sure that looks pretty
intuitive Yep this really just um more
talking about where our investments have
been
um from the federal government so the
feds are saying to us especially now
um and these are also it also represents
our needs you know between the two the
feds are saying you need to build up
your Workforce not only in those Public
Health nurses in the laboratory but
there are other capabilities and again
the theme you will hear is around data
analysis epidemiology informatics you
know those folks are are the folks that
we need to continue to try and attract
um to build some of those foundational
capabilities so we can do things like
electronic case reporting
um we're almost over the Finish Line
with every with the hospitals being able
to do it
um but that that's important again
background information that you and I
and the public don't see every every day
but we need to make sure our hospitals
have the ability to report cases to us
electronically Laboratories have the
ability to report to us electronically
as well straight from their ehrs that's
the piece there it's a informatics in
hl7 connection
um I think the other thing that I would
I would like to highlight is that not
only did we buff up public Health's
response the division of Public Health
response we also put an extraordinary
amount of money out into the community
um
we put money in our regional public
health networks
we put them into Hospital Systems all
our health Care Systems we develop
strengthening around mobile Integrated
Health that's where we work with EMS to
do some newer ways to treat things that
aren't even coveted related but around
heart disease and chronic disease and
trying to find new ways especially in
places like the North Country to have
additional resources available to
individuals we've deployed an army of
you know 20 some odd community health
workers out into communities that have
been able to ensure that families get
access to health care and the social
services they need and we've tried to
put in money to support our local
providers in training and supplies
um as well so again that's this has been
a direction from the federal government
but also what we've recognized
representative Wallner had asked the
commissioner question about our vendors
you know a lot of our community
Investments are hampered because our
Community Partners don't have the staff
to do the work so when we developed a
grant and said to the cdcu we're going
to do XYZ
um there are a number of cases where we
couldn't actually execute on what we
said because our partner simply said I
can't get the staff
and so that's where we're seeing some of
that that um trickle down
um I I do have a question about it
please so so so that's certainly the
good news the other side of that coin on
the community Investments is that we've
created a flow of money into the
communities that's gonna
it's on trajectory to dry up so what
kind of pent-up demand is going to
remain for those resources when we
unwind so I I think it's going to be a
couple of things I mean we've tried to
be thoughtful and do sort of one-time
Investments it's why we focused on
training that's why we focused on
supplies you know those sorts of pieces
there have been obvious places community
health workers is a great example where
we've invested in people we don't have a
plan post you know in state fiscal year
26 how those community health workers
are going to continue to be funded will
determine as a state whether that's
all right that's that's a big deal
that's next budget I think okay
um but you know maybe Mr White could
start creating a list off to the side
that says okay here here are some places
we need to look to see what the impact
is on unwinding I I wouldn't make that a
big priority in anything fancy but I I
would like to be able to come back if
I'm still around in two years to say
okay let's let's talk about what the
plan is to unwind what do we need to
worry about yeah
yes you know our goal all along we've
known the money is like you know
Cinderella's pumpkin like it's gonna go
away we knew this from the first day it
dropped on us and so we've tried to be
as thoughtful and conservative in that
approach knowing that we didn't want to
build systems we couldn't maintain
all right uh representable thank you I'm
looking at this page yes not page
numbers right 18 it says the clock is
ticking clock is ticking
um 18 18 right and I guess so so if I
heard you correctly right you're
thinking about not just this budget but
the budget the next biennium yes
what would be bad would be a huge step
function on August 1st 2024 right I
think that's the thing that we have to
avoid so not just thinking about it in
the next budget cycle I think we
actually have to think about it in this
budget cycle such that
whatever
the necessary need is on August 1st that
year that you've already hit that ramp
level during the second well whatever
the fourth half of the year of this
budget cycle right the the January to
June time frame in 2024 that you've
already done those ramp Downs because
otherwise no one likes step functions
when it comes to labor pools right
either up or down you can't find you
suddenly need 30 people and you can't
find them or you suddenly have 30 excess
people that you need to tell them they
need to go home and tell their wives
they can't work here anymore
um and both of those anomalies we'd like
to avoid so I'd like from you some plan
that talk that's part of this budget
cycle that talks about what the ramp is
to deal with this by the end of this
biennium thank you did I say that
correctly
you know I loved everything you just
said but could you just summarize your
last sentence of what your request is so
so that I I would like the department
knowing that these funds are running out
right July of 2024 to have a plan in
place that's presented to us to bring us
so you share with us what the long-term
need is well I need 10 of these people
to do X going forward because that's
what we think we need that plan needs to
be given to us as part of this budget
cycle because I think the ramp down
happens this time not next time I thank
you I really appreciate that and you
know I'll point back to you that we have
been doing we've been having a dynamic
response all along again 200 staff we're
down to 40. you know we've been able to
flex that
um as much as possible because quite
frankly it was unsustainable the work
that we were doing was unsustainable and
what I think what all of you are
suggesting and we as well is that we
need to understand what's sustainable
for the future and what that might cost
and what that might look like you know
what's what's needed and what's what is
sustainable so I think we can work on
that we know that um the the little bit
of the tricky part for us is that even
though these uh funds say they're going
to expire in 24 we anticipate that many
of them are going to give us an extra
year so as we get closer we will likely
have what's called a no-cost extension
which is you can continue to spend down
any funds that you did not spend in your
Grant in the next coming year that's
what um that's certainly what we're
seeing already with funds that have
already started to expire we've been
seeing these no cost extensions for
another year which is why
um I I don't want to minimize the impact
of what happens on August 1 and 24 but
my hunch is we will have a number of
resources to get us over that hump 26 is
really when when I'm gonna say fiscal
year 26 is really going to be the the
time that's different and and to your
point we need to be planning for all of
I I would only ask that you share with
us those plans right because I think
that will be in fact part of this budget
cycle as we start thinking about whether
for instance maybe the I.T side needs
more staff long term because we're
spending more time in energy managing
data than you anticipated two years ago
that's an example but the laboratory
automation side has has fundamentally
changed and now it's it's very much
automated and there's less people
actually doing tests in the lab for
example great thank you I appreciate
that yeah
so I hear the request request sounds
rational uh I I'm just telling you as
I'm I'm thinking through how we went
through the budget last year I'm not
exactly sure how that information would
be conveyed in what I'm expecting to be
are you know the high hurdles of agency
budget running you know but but you know
I'll leave it to Mr Ripple and Mr White
and Miss Tilly to kind of figure out how
to how to bring us that information in
an actionable way I I don't have a view
of it right now it might be Staffing
levels anticipated Staffing levels right
at that time right so Staffing levels
are X today and Staffing levels we see
at the end of this period of time we
think this is going to shrink down to
this number this is going to grow
some of that information might be
available where you see the direction of
each of those departments going so if
that can be shared even is just a high
level document would be helpful sure
thank you I will wrap up then it's sort
of the almost the third to last slide
says future Workforce Challenge and I
think this there are no numbers here but
this is this is getting where you want
um it you know we currently have about
40 to 49 positions that are these
temporary State positions that are
in and out of being filled
um the nature of temporary positions is
even when we get somebody in them they
know it's temporary so they tend to not
always stick around either so it's a lot
of managing in and out
um and then we have some stack temporary
staffing contracts you know I don't
think you know come that come this time
next year and certainly by August of of
um the next fiscal year I don't
anticipate we're going to be needing all
of that but I I do know that we will
need some of that it's probably not
going to be that level
um I think the areas again that I would
tell you to forecast that we're going to
need some infrastructure support is
around laboratory informatics that's the
big one emergency preparedness and
response we've gotten you know we've
been able to respond for that you know
to this with a lot of federal resources
those resources all go away very soon to
your point uh representative Edwards
data analysis and epidemiology right
there in black and white and then of
course you know one of the the
Investments I think in the community
that has been popular is community
health workers so I can wrap up there
everyone's putting their stuff no that's
a tour de force that's uh that's
excellent
um are there any questions for Miss
you'll always be Miss Tilly to me I'm so
sorry Trisha
Patty okay
so uh so so no thank you for for all of
this and uh if the members of the
division could just stick stick around
for like four more minutes I'd
appreciate it we're gonna we're gonna
let you go
um Mr White you've heard a lot you got
any last minute stuff for us that you've
heard
okay Mr Collins I see you back there
you've been listening do you have
anything for the good of the community
all right okay so uh I'm not going to do
this every time but since this is our
first time and because I've been trying
to interject some some places where the
folks providing us testimony would slow
down and go into detail
on the assumption that the new members
of the division and the new members to
finance May benefit from from hearing
some of the more basic stuff I think
it's cost us an extra 15-20 minutes
today you know and the rest of it is me
learning stuff but so I want to get your
feedback and do I is it okay for me to
worry about making sure that some of
this basic training stuff is included as
we go or would you rather me just try to
run it faster
I appreciate it very much
okay I do feel it's a learning process
and if it only cost us 15 minutes then I
thank the committee for giving us that
time
ditto
I agree
okay good so now I have a get out of
jail card for like holding really long
meetings
okay so anyone at this point
representative norgren do you have in a
summary or anything you want to add or
oh okay uh anyone how about you Mr
Ripple where are we at what what what do
we know about Friday that we should say
um well you know so I think included in
the email I sent out the other day is
the brief list of presentations in order
that you plan on seeing on Friday I
don't have that in front of me at the
moment uh I did want to point out though
I think everybody received an email from
Janet earlier today there's also a work
session scheduled on Friday at 11 on
House Bill 49 so I didn't want you to
foreign
to say that again
House Bill 49 which is uh I'm the prime
sponsor in that that's the that's the
short-term extension that we were
talking about representative walner with
some money uh thrown at it we're gonna
we're gonna have a work session on that
at 11 o'clock on Friday
we don't have a room yet do we
um I think it's two 201 I was hoping we
I was hoping we would get into 210 211.
and that reminds me I may be late for
that one as we previously discussed okay
do you think you're gonna have an
amendment to that or uh because I I
it'll work there before it's over but
but no I don't have any plans for that
but I do think I'll get that before it's
over I just might be a little bit late
okay so if anyone has an amendment to HP
49 even if it's just in a Word document
that we could look at and talk about I I
think you know given the
urgency of the sununu Center closing
rapidly I I just would really like us to
do what we could to
um not to not to foreclose what the
decision ought to be but to try to
accelerate a good discussion
um anything else they're miserable
do you do we know enough to talk about
I think there's going to be
a full committee public hearing on Two
Bills the morning of the ninth one is
Senate bill one and the other one is
House Bill
257 I believe and then following those
public hearings there will be a division
three work session on
at a minimum Senate bill one I think for
calendar purposes Janice is going to put
in all three bills that are currently in
division so Senate bill one house bill
49 and House Bill 257. and what you end
up working on you end up working on but
at least they'll all be calendared and
then once that work session is complete
I think the
the expectation is that there will be a
full committee exec session on Senate
bill 1.
that afternoon
okay
yes the room isn't available on the 8th
it's a Wednesday so Health and Human
Services has the room
oh oh okay so in anticipate I think
it'll start at 10 o'clock
okay so
um so in anticipation of any concern
about the the moving on sb1 so quickly
after a work session of division three
next week I just would point out that by
the time we talk on Friday about HP 49
an amendment I've had drafted uh we we
will have us we will have covered all of
the ground that's in sb1 so so it's
almost like we're going to have two
bytes of the Apple in terms of the
issues and you'll have time to spend the
weekend thinking about it and before we
come back to sb1 you'll have plenty of
time to think about it on a relative
scale I think so that that that's what
I'm I'm thinking I I the only thing I'm
losing sleep over these days is uh what
happens on one March when the sununity
center is legally required to close
that's the only thing I will lose sleep
over
so uh any anybody uh representative hole
can someone explain to me what the plan
is for Friday in terms of hearings
because I heard an overlap I just want
to make sure I understand and I haven't
gotten through all the we're talking
Friday the third uh yes yes you want to
do that Mr Ripple
sure so there'll be a work session on
House Bill 49 in the morning at 11 A.M
and then at 1 pm you'll be back for uh
some more presentations from the
department and I think I sent her out an
email earlier with that tentative
schedule thank you I just saw our
so without seeing any other questions or
discussion this is sort of a good of the
community session here uh we can we can
go ahead and close I don't see a need to
do one of these after Action reviews
every time but I just since this is our
first one I wanted to make sure that we
were just in sync with each other with
foreign